So, vielleicht sollte ich die Musik ausmachen, sonst ist es irgendwie doppelt, ne?
Moin!
Und moin Michael, 50 Billiarden!
Erinnern wir uns sonst noch, der Netto Assi ist am Start Bass-Fanation, das habe ich jetzt
richtig gesagt, Burbel, der Apfel, ne zum Glück, ich weiß zu schätzen, dass es nicht
der Apple ist, sondern der Apfel, RealRenax ist da, Mark Yolo, ein Zombien-Dude, der Arkenas99,
ist auch wieder am Start, Gabbyxx, PClustig und Herz93 ist auch am Start, exellent!
So, jetzt machen wir das mal zu, ich fand das bloß toll, wie sich hier die Emotes langschieben.
Ist eigentlich nicht mehr Morgens, ja das ist richtig, das ist korrekt!
Aber es ist früh, das reicht, ich habe so viel Crap laufen auf meinem Vorschau-Rechner,
das muss ich gerade mal alles ausschalten, da startet immer noch Skype automatisch,
ich weiß gar nicht, wie sieht denn, benutzt irgendjemand von euch überhaupt noch Skype?
Wie sieht denn das jetzt mittlerweile aus?
Skype 2020, wie sieht denn das jetzt mittlerweile aus?
Ok, das sieht aus wie ein Teams-Klon, das sieht aus wie ein Teams-Klon, ich habe das
wirklich schon seit Jahren nicht mehr aufgehabt, das letzte Skype, was ich kenne, war so von
2016 oder so, genau, das ist das letzte Skype, was ich kenne, so sah das noch aus.
Skype, 15er ESS-Docking, oh das glaubt, das gucken wir heute nicht, ich glaube, das gucken
wir nicht.
Ah ja, hier sieht man mal wieder, was die Leute bewegt, kann man ficken, trotz Corona
und was Merkel erzählt hat, das ist ein bisschen, also das eine und das andere in Kombination
ist ein bisschen schwierig miteinander zu vereinbaren, ja, aber gut, haben die nichts
anderes zu tun, ich glaube, das kleinste Problem, was es gibt, ob das über das Sperma zu übertragen
ist, Alter, ich mein, das liegt in der Natur der Sache, dass man sich relativ nahe kommt,
wenn das hier ein Problem ist, dann ist alles andere vorher eh schon gelaufen und es hat
sich schon übertragen, direkt 290.000 Views, ja klar, solche Sachen gehen immer, sowas
geht immer, mich würde mal das Like-Dislike-Verhältnis interessieren, wir gucken uns das jetzt nicht
an, keine Sorge, viele Leute sehen das ähnlich, dass es ein schwachsinniges Thema ist, die
Kommentare, okay, also, primitive Themenausschlachtung, sind sie wieder, Abstand im E-Med-Bett für
die meisten kein Problem, ja, aber eine gewisse Dauer mit Sicherheit, das ist wohl wahr, ey,
wenn eins geht, dann ist es das hier, da fällt mir nur eine Sache zu einer, ist die Musik
nicht ein bisschen zu laut, oder ist es nur bei mir so, nee, ich glaube, das geht eigentlich
ganz gut gerade, also, da fällt mir nur eine Sache zu einem, zu diesem Comment, das ist
echt, das bestätigt, wenn eins geht, ist, dass die Leute irgendwie Nachwuchszeugen
und miteinander treiben, und zwar, ich musste mal vom Arbeitsamt einen Kurs machen, ich
glaube, das habe ich sogar schon mal erzählt, und die Leute in diesem Kurs, also, wenn ich
mal sage, das war Unterschicht, dann ist es noch nett ausgedrückt, ja, aber, ey, also,
okay, dann erzähle ich das jetzt mal kurz, wie gesagt, ich musste mal so einen How-To-Bewerbungskurs
machen vom Arbeitsamt, das ist ewig her, das war lange, bevor ich die aktuelle Ausbildung
angefangen habe, eine ganze Weile davor noch, das müsste so 2001 oder so rum gewesen sein,
also das ist wirklich schon, oder, warte mal, 2001, warte mal, ich bin 1984 geboren, ich
war 16, 2000, 17, 18, nee, eher so 2004, so in dem Dreh, was auch immer, da musste ich
zu so einem Kurs beim Arbeitsamt, wie sieht es eigentlich, wie sieht es eigentlich, wie
sieht es eigentlich, das heißt ja nicht mal Arbeitsamt, wie, Hanau, gleich automatisch
vervollständigt, exzellent, was haben die jetzt eigentlich für ein Logo mittlerweile?
Oh, Hi-Res, Hi-Res Background hier, seht ihr das, exzellent Background hier, absolut Hi-Res
Background, die wissen, wie es funktioniert, na gut, zumindest musste ich den Kurs machen
und da ging es darum, wie man halt richtig Bewerbung schreibt, und die Leute, die da
waren, die konnten entweder nicht richtig Deutsch, geschweige denn sich auch nur ansatzweise
mal verständlich ausdrücken schriftlich, da war zum Beispiel eine, die hat sich beschwert,
dass immer, wenn sie was an das Amt schreibt, die antworten, die antworten nicht, oder wenn
sie antworten, dann versteht sie die antworten nicht, bzw. sie antworten nie auf das, was
sie geschrieben hat, da habe ich mir so gedacht, hä, warum und so, und da hat die mir mal
ein Brief von sich gezeigt, meine Fresse ey, kein Wunder, dass sie den nicht richtig geantwortet
haben, die haben sie einfach nicht verstanden, die halt konnte wirklich keinen Satz, die
konnte keinen Satz schreiben, dass man es versteht, ich hatte, ich hatte wirklich legit auch
keinen Plan, nachdem ich das gelesen habe, man, die Wörter waren nicht wirklich Wörter
am Ende, ja, also, also wenn ich hier einen Brief schreiben würde, aus allen Twitch Emotes,
die ich hier habe, wäre das verständlicher, als was sie geschrieben hat, und das beste
war da noch, ähm, also die konnte ja auch sonst nix, also ich mein, wenn schon, wenn
es schon an einfache Sätze schreiben scheitert, dann, ähm, aber das, aber das, das, das
beste war ja, ähm, ja, ich hab, ich hab ihr dann gesagt, ja, ok, was willst du ihnen
denn sagen, dann hab ich ihr gesagt, ok, schreib ich immer zwei, drei, zwei, zwei, drei Sätze
auf, und dann hab ich dann das versucht zu erklären, so nach dem Motto, guck mal, ähm,
du, mach, mach doch einfach einfache Sätze, die hat übelst lange Sätze gemacht, mach
doch einfach einfache Sätze, so nach dem Motto, ähm, ich brauche Miete für die Wohnung,
so nach dem Motto, so irgendwas, irgendwas einfaches, ne, und da hat die wirklich gesagt,
das hab ich, das hab ich aber schonmal irgendwo erzählt in dem Video, da hat die wirklich
gesagt, ähm, sie muss nicht lesen und schreiben können, weil ihr Freund kann das, das war
wirklich legit Antwort, aber sich aufregen, dass die Leute das nicht verstehen, das ist,
was ne, was ne Erklärung, ich muss nicht lesen und schreiben können, weil mein Mann das kann,
ich mein, es geht hier nicht um Klavierspielen oder so, ja, also, wahrgenommen, einer kann
Geige spielen oder Klavierspielen, da kann man sagen, oh ja, das ist cool, ähm, das muss
ich aber nicht können, ich find's aber cool, dass man, dass mein Mann, meine Frau und sonst
was kann, das spielt man ab und zu was vor, toll, ähm, aber lesen und schreiben, ja, die
waren toll, ach ja, und by the way, noch was, noch was, sie war natürlich schwanger, weil
irgendwie alle Mädels, die in diesem Kurs waren, entweder schon Mutter waren oder gerade
schwanger waren oder gut daran gearbeitet haben, schwanger zu werden, wahrscheinlich
weil sie sich gedacht haben, dann läuft das mit dem Arbeitsamt besser, keine Ahnung, aber
sie war schwanger und hat öffentlich die ganze Zeit rum erzählt, dass sie permanent
es mit zwei Typen treibt, das wolltest du gar nicht wissen, ja, da hat die dir das erzählt
und hat sie immer noch danach gesagt, so nach dem Motto, ja, aber wenn das Kind erst mal
da ist, dann ist damit Schluss, was interessiert's mich, Alter, jetzt wird's mich jucken, ja,
es war wirklich so absolute big brain Erfahrung und da waren so viele fertige Leute da, da
war auch der Typ, der Rapper werden wollte, das hab ich euch schon erzählt, machst du
Faxen, das hab ich euch schon erzählt, machst du Faxen, der deutsche Rapper werden wollte,
der Typ, das war, ich sag jetzt nicht den ersten Namen, ich sag mal Mustafa, es war
ein türkischer Name, ja, und der war, der war 18 gerade geworden, höchstens, vielleicht
war er auch erst 16, 17 oder so, und moin, um was geht's, er zählt gerade, wo ich einen
Bewerbungskurs beim Arbeitsamt machen musste, aber ich weiß, was ich dir schon mal erzählt
hab, zumindest, der Typ wollte halt krasser Deutsch, genau, genau, da, Kizaru, du kennst
das noch, der wollte halt krasser Deutsch Rapper werden, der Typ, und da hat er noch
immer Texte geschrieben und nachdem ich ja wohl einer der wenigen dort war, der ordentlich
lesen und schreiben konnte, haben wir halt irgendwann gesagt, ja, zeig doch, zeig doch
mal her, der hat immer Riesenklappe gehabt, der hat immer Riesenklappe gehabt, aber gut,
es liegt so in der Natur der Leute, umso weniger im Hirn, umso wichtiger muss man tun, und
dann hat er mir einen Text von sich gezeigt, ich hab nur angefangen zu lesen, ich hab mir
das nicht ausgedacht, muss man vielleicht noch mal sagen, weil das so total hängen geblieben
ist, stand dann, ich konnte es nicht mal weiter lesen danach, stand dann im Intro, machst
du Faxen, mach ich dich platt mit Achsen, das war sein krasser Deutschrap, und als ich
dann angefangen hab zu lachen, hat er mir das abgenommen, hat er mir das abgenommen
und meinte dann so, ich soll nicht weiter lesen, es war ihm voll peinlich, ich hab nie
erlebt, dass dem was peinlich ist, das war ihm aber peinlich, ich hab eh den Eindruck,
um Deutschrapper zu werden, oder um deutsche, deutschen, weiß ich, deutschen Pop oder deutschen
Hip-Hop oder sowas in der Richtung zu machen, deutsche Mainstream Musik sagen wir mal zu
machen, du brauchst, also zumindest die, die auch angesagt ist, jetzt nicht irgendwie Helene
Fischer bei den älteren Leuten, sondern die auch im jüngeren Segment angesagt ist, ich
glaub das wichtigste was du brauchst ist, um da deutsche Musik aktuell zu machen, deutschsprachliche
Musik ist, du brauchst einfach nur ein Charme Level, was niedrig genug ist, was da teilweise
für Texte gibt, das ist wirklich an Primitivität und Low Brain, Low IQ nicht mehr zu unterbieten,
aber die meisten Leute machen es nicht, weil sie schämen würden sowas zu singen, aber
es gibt halt Leute, die haben da keinerlei Schamgefühl mehr und die singen dann halt
diesen Rotz und es ist dann sogar teilweise auch noch erfolgreich, wie auch immer, ja
und zumindest eine Sache, was halt bei diesem Arbeitsamtkurs halt auch echt beeindruckend
war irgendwo, dass die alle schon schwanger waren oder Kinder hatten, die waren so, ich
war da relativ, ich war da mit keine Ahnung 22 oder so, 21 oder so war ich da, das heißt
ich war schon ein bisschen älter als die meisten anderen Leute, die da waren und ohne Scheiß
die waren alle, die waren 18 kind, 19 nixes kind, die hatten nix anderes zu tun, als nachwuchs
zu zeugen den ganzen Tag, das kann jeder und das fällt mir nur ein, was mir hier, wo war
es denn jetzt hier, was mir zu diesem Comment hier halt eingefallen ist, das geht immer,
egal ob arbeitslos, ob man Geld hat, ob man ein Haus hat, ob man, fick nur Nachwuchszeugen,
das kriegen sie alle hin und das war so offensichtlich in diesem Arbeitsamtkurs, das ist der Wahnsinn,
das hätte ich nie gedacht, ja also, ja das war auch mal eine Erfahrung, wo ich jetzt
sagen würde, okay, die Kammern gemacht haben, die muss man nicht unbedingt gemacht haben,
es war aber im Nachhinein gar nicht so schlecht, weil ich dann erstmal gesehen habe, wie dumm
man wirklich sein kann, bei den Leuten, die da waren, also wie dumm man im Durchschnitt
wirklich sein kann, da gab es 2-3 Leute, die waren einfach nur faul wie ich und hatten
keinen Bock sich damals eine Ausbildung zu suchen und der Rest, der war einfach schlicht
und ergreifend zu dumm, 2-3 Worte in der richtigen Reihenfolge hintereinander zu schreiben und
nicht etwa, weil sie es nicht konnten, weil sie es nicht gelernt hätten oder so, sondern
weil sie zu doof waren, also sprich, wenn jetzt jemand, gerade sagen wir mal, wenn jetzt
irgendwie einer aus Südkorea herkommt, dann geht es klar kein Wunder, dass der nicht sofort
irgendwie super deutschen Text schreiben kann, aber das waren Leute, die waren alle in Deutschland
geboren, die sind in Deutschland in die Schule gegangen und die konnten keine 3 Wörter richtig
schreiben, geschweige denn an der richtigen Reihenfolge hintereinander und so gehäuft,
das waren, ich sage jetzt 25 Leute ungefähr und davon konnten 20 nicht lesen und schreiben
richtig.
Da habe ich erst mal gesehen, wie extrem das ist in manchen Bildungsfernen Schichten, richtig
hart, das hätte ich nicht gedacht und die haben mich da teilweise behandelt wie den
übelsten Guru, weil ich Briefe schreiben konnte, die kamen dann alle an und haben gemeint ob
ich mal angucken kann, lesen kann, ob ich vielleicht das irgendwie verbessern konnte
oder so, ich war gefühlt der einzige, der lesen und schreiben konnte und die kamen dann
so, oh der Max ist voll schlau, der Max ist voll schlau, der Max kann, Alter, ich konnte
Sätze schreiben, das war alles, was ich konnte im Vergleich zu denen mehr, ja und die haben
wirklich gedacht, dass ich bin der übelste Guru, weil ich meine deutschen Sätze schreiben
konnte, das war schon lustig, ja.
Oh man, das war echt so eine Erfahrung, die muss eigentlich, die muss nicht sein, ja und
die nächste Sache, die ich danach gemacht habe, danach habe ich ja gesagt, Arbeitsamt
kann mich machen, ich mache Zivildienst und da muss ich sagen, das ist eine Sache, wo
ich schade finde, dass es das nicht mehr gibt, weil ich habe es ja auch schon mal erzählt,
ich habe das ja in einer Behindertenwerkstatt gemacht und das war im Prinzip eher, es hieß
zwar Werkstatt, aber sag mal mal so, was die Leute da gewerkt haben oder erstellt haben
oder so, das war jetzt nicht irgendwie relevant oder so, die haben Tüten zugeklebt und solche
Sachen, also das war eher eine Betreuung, die quasi den Anschein erweckt hat und den
Leuten das Gefühl gegeben hat, es ist wichtig, was sie machen, was ja vom Inhalt her nicht
verkehrt ist, wenn die Leute quasi das Gefühl haben, sie machen irgendwas, was relevant
ist, was wichtig ist, da sind die ja auch besser drauf, aber im Prinzip war es eher so eine
Art Betreuung mit ein bisschen Handwerkssachen dabei, zumindest diese, was waren das, neun
Monate oder so, neun Monate, zehn Monate, neun Monate, ich glaube ich zehn, ich weiß
nicht genau, sag mal knapp einen Jahr, Zivildienst in einer Behindertenwerkstatt, das ist wirklich
eine Sache, ich habe mir am Anfang übelst schwer getan, da irgendwie klarzukommen mit,
aber das könnte ich aber wirklich, wie sagt man so, bedingungslos, also ruhigen Gewissens
jedem empfehlen, das zu machen, das geht ja aktuell nicht mehr bzw. freiwillig macht
sowas ja auch keiner, warum sollte man das freiwillig machen, man wurde ja dadurch irgendwo
gezwungen, entweder musste man zum Mund oder man musste Zivildienst machen, also irgendwas
musste man machen, aber rein die Erfahrung kann ich wirklich jedem empfehlen, weil man
hat am Anfang erst mal übelst Berührungsängste, man geht dahin, du hast Leute um dich, die
haben alle total den Knall, das ist zumindest das erste was man denkt, der eine kackt auf
den Gang, das ist jetzt kein Witz, das kommt da öfters mal vor, der eine kackt auf den
Gang, der andere dreht sich den ganzen Zeit auf seinem Stuhl im Kreis bis er kotzen muss,
der nächste will einfach nur seine Ruhe sitzen in der Ecke, klebt 15.000 Tüten am Tag,
also du denkst, die haben alle einen Knall und letztendlich sind sie ja nicht ohne Grund,
die haben ja auch alle irgendwo einen Knall, aber was man mit der Zeit merkt, wenn man in
so einer Behindertenwerkstalle ist, ich denke mal generell, wenn man irgendwo mit Behinderten
arbeitet, dass am Anfang alles so einheitlich erscheint, du denkst dir, alter die haben alle
einen Knall, denkt man sich am Anfang so, aber umso länger man dabei ist, umso mehr erkennt
man, dass auch da die Leute alle unterschiedlich sind und du weißt mit der Zeit, okay das
ist der und der, der hat der und den Tick und eigentlich, wenn man das macht, findet
er das ganz toll und das andere findet er nicht gut und der mag den nicht und eigentlich
kann man sich auch ziemlich gut denken, warum, weil der eine will seine Ruhe haben und der
andere schreit immer rum, das ist auf total simplem Level irgendwo in der Stelle, aber
da faked auch keiner irgendwas, also wenn du den fragst, so nach dem Motto, hier sag
mal, wie findest du den, dann sagt der, alter voll der Spaß, also sagt der nicht, der sagt
das, der sagt was anderes, der würde sagen, oh der ist voll dumm oder sowas, der lügt
dich nicht an oder so, der sagt einfach wie es ist, ja Real Relax das stimmt, es gibt
keine ehrlicheren Menschen, also da ist wirklich, warte mal, bei mir ist gerade im Flur irgendwas
umgefallen glaube ich, warte mal kurz.
Ja keine Ahnung, ich glaube die Katze hat irgendwas runtergeschmissen, ja also, genau,
also das ist echt was, jetzt muss er den schnell den Speer aus dem Flur holen, ja ja, der ist
immer in der Nähe der Speer, und die Armbrust auch, da muss ja im Zweifelsfall was bereit
haben, wenn ihr mal irgendwann eine anrückt, wenn die Corona Zombie Apokalypse doch noch
startet, naja zumindest unabstrich kann ich sagen, das ist wirklich eine Sache, die ich
jedem empfehlen kann das mal zu machen, man kommt da mit Leuten in Kontakt, wie gesagt
ich bin niemand der gerne mit Leuten in Kontakt kommt, das hab ich ja schon oft gesagt, soziale
Sachen sind ja für mich, gehen mir voll am Arsch vorbei, ich will eigentlich mit anderen
Leuten gar nichts zu tun haben, aber das war echt nicht schlecht im Nachhinein, ich hab
mir da am Anfang auch schwer getan, aber das war nicht verkehrt, und das ist auch eine
Sache die mir auch heute noch so ein bisschen am Herzen liegt ist, dass dort viel zu wenig
Geld reinfließt, dass dort viel zu wenig Geld reinfließt, die haben nix im Endeffekt
dort, sprich da gab es Tage, die haben Mittagessen aus dem Krankenhaus bekommen, das waren gefühlt
die Abfälle, das war das ekligste Mittagessen ever, was ich je gegessen hab, da gab es Tage,
da war noch nicht mal Klopapier ausreichend da, die haben nix in so einer Behindertenwerkstatt
gehabt, das ist wirklich die Pfeifen auf dem allerletzten Loch was Finanzen angeht, weil
es halt keine Werkstatt im eigentlichen Sinn ist, wo irgendwas wirklich produziert wird,
das Geld verdient, das ist halt eigentlich, wie gesagt, das ist eine Betreuung tagsüber
für die Leute eigentlich, die ihnen das Gefühl geben soll, dass sie halt etwas wichtiges
machen, also da wird nichts produziert, was irgendwie Geld bringt, da fließt viel zu
wenig Geld rein und ich glaube eines der Punkte ist, dass die Leute einfach schlicht und ergreifend
absolut keine Lobby haben, wer macht Werbung beziehungsweise wer agiert hier in Deutschland
schon für die Interessen von Behinderten, gibt es doch eigentlich kaum was, mir fällt
jetzt nix ein, jede andere Minderheit hat doch mehr Lobbyarbeit als solche Leute, da fließt
viel zu wenig Geld rein und wenn man sich teilweise die Wohnheime da anguckt, da fällt
der Putz von den Wänden und so, das ist voll fürn Arsch, außer den Eltern setzt sich da
keiner fürn, ja ist so, und oftmals ist ja halt auch so, dass die Leute werden ja heute
auch älter als früher, die Eltern leben halt teilweise auch nicht mehr und den Leuten
gehts wirklich nicht gut, aber es interessiert keine Sau, auf der einen Seite erzählen wir
immer, ah wir haben alle so viel Geld, was wir ja im Durchschnitt so, fragt euch mal
selbst, gar nicht haben, aber wir stecken das überall rein, aber nicht da, naja, Marc Pla
sagt Bildungssektor sowieso broken, wäre das, würde das auch dazu zählen, ja vielleicht
und eine Sache, jetzt weil du grad sag Bildungssektor, eine Sache, die mir da auch echt leid tut
ist, es gibt viele behinderte Leute, die ich da gesehen hab, es wird heute nicht anders
sein, das war jetzt schon wieder 15 Jahre her, aber ich glaub nicht, dass es sich großartig
geändert hat, die könnten viel mehr als den ganzen Tag da beim Tüten zu kleben vor sich
hin zu vegetieren, da gab es welche, die wollten tatsächlich lesen lernen und sowas
und die konnten auch ein bisschen, die haben sich das teilweise selbst beigebracht und
viele könnten dort um ein Vielfaches mehr machen und auch mehr hier big brain werden,
als sie überhaupt die Möglichkeiten dazu haben, weil ich mein, da ist ja niemand da,
der sich irgendwie mal mit denen hinsetzt und was lernt oder ist auch keiner da, der
wirklich mal gezielt sich 3, 4 Leute, die halt Bereich Interesse haben und vielleicht
auch Potential haben, mit denen da was zu lernen, das kannst du komplett vergessen,
gibt's nicht, die sind schon froh, wenn die genug Leute haben, dass die 40, 50 Leute teilweise
pro Gruppe betreuen können, Realtalk aus dem DX Racer, ich hab keinen DX Racer, ich hab
keinen DX, was soll ich mit dem DX Racer, ich hab mal einen DX Racer, der DX Racer
ist kaputt gegangen, ich hab jetzt einen bester Stuhl ever hier, bester Stuhl, besseren Stuhl
gibt's nicht, excellent, ja bester Stuhl, ja der echte Proxy, da hab ich meine Bedenken,
wie gut das funktioniert, weil die Anforderungen sind ja schon unterschiedlich, das ist aber
bester, bester Stuhl, Ikea Markus, Ikea Markus ist auch nicht schlecht, ich glaub der Friseur
hat immer noch Ikea Markus, jeder YouTuber hat einen DX Racer, seht ihr Leute, ich bin
derzeit wieder in dem Fall voraus, ich hatte einen DX Racer und hab jetzt einen besseren,
der Friseur hat glaub ich immer noch Ikea Markus, so aber das ist der beste, ja übrigens
den normalen Preis würde ich dafür nicht bezahlen, das ist total bescheuert, 1,5k für
einen Stuhl, müsst gucken, dass ihr den billiger kriegt und ihr kriegt den auch in der Regel
immer billiger, bisschen billiger, Dual Commentary mit dem Stuhl, mit Stühle, mit dem Friseur,
der Friseur braucht grad keinen Stuhl mehr, der ist ja die ganze Zeit am Mobile Games
spielen, so also was schlägt uns denn YouTube heute schönes vor, ich hab schon ein paar
Sachen aufgemacht, was, die sind doch gestern schon gestartet?
Hä, was geht denn das los?
Der Dogball an der ISS an, ja in 4 Stunden oder so, Mister Robot Decryption Scene, ich
muss ja sagen, die erste Hälfte von Mister Robot, also die erste Hälfte von der ersten
Staffel Mister Robot fand ich richtig gut, danach war's Crap, so schlimm, dass ich danach
überhaupt die zweite Staffel sogar hab ich mir überhaupt nicht mehr angeguckt und was
ich an Reviews gesehen habe, wurde es im Prinzip noch schlimmer, weniger Technik, sondern mehr
psychogestörte Sachen vom Hauptcharakter, gar nicht mehr im Anfall, die erste Hälfte
war richtig gut.
Was war das erste Dual mit dem Friseur, ich hab keine Ahnung, das müsste eines der ersten
Videos sogar schon gewesen sein, gucken wir mal, gucken wir mal was das erste Video mit
dem Friseur war, das müsste eines der ersten Videos sogar schon gewesen sein, falls ich
es nicht gelöscht hab, äh, all ist, HS Yohi, 6 Monate, exellent, oh falsch hier, high IQ,
nicht low IQ, dankeschön, also das erste, die erste 1-2 Videos hab ich gelöscht, weil
die hatten Musik drinne und das ging nicht richtig, warum ausgerechnet das erste Video
so viele Views haben, weiß ich nicht, genau, ähm, wo ist das erste Video mit dem Friseur,
das hab ich gelöscht oder, weil da irgendwie Musik drinne war, weil ich kann mich noch
dran erinnern, dass ich im Abspann, dass ich im Abspann vom allerersten Video, was ich
gelöscht habe, drinstehen hatte, dass das nächste Video mit dem Friseur ist, wo ist
der Friseur am Start, hier, das war, war das echt das erste, ne, glaub ich nicht, ich
glaube, da gabs noch mehr, das ist aber noch nicht am Start gewesen, Shotguns, oh man,
das ging aber auch nur, also wir haben damals auch nur so viele Videos gemacht, so viel
zu einem Thema und auch so viel zusammen, weil es halt ein Game war, wo wir uns richtig
reingesteigert haben, ne, also wir haben ja Tag ein, Tag aus nichts anderes gespielt und
ich wünsche mir, dass es mal wieder ein Game gibt, was ich in der Ausführlichkeit, ähm,
durchgrinden kann, wie dort manch, manch in Game, ja, Uno, wo Uno mit der Simona gespielt
hat, kann mich auch dran erinnern, oh man, genau das ist vom Fabian hier, wo er, wo er,
ähm, sein Prestige 15 Level 50 mit so ner, mit so nem komischen Generator gemacht hat,
ja, übelst rolliges Crap Setup, Steakout, China Lake Granatenwerfer, Linewide Slane
Offendmacher, das ist total red, Scepter and Cam Package Gunship, das ist total für
n Arsch, ja, den Bardsong hatte ich mal im Outro, ja, ja, aber nachgespielt natürlich,
nicht den offiziellen, nicht den offiziellen, hätt ich den offiziellen im Outro genommen,
das wäre schlecht gewesen, ja, äh, was haben wir denn für Stats am Ende, zeig mal her,
ja, 25.10, das war damals ein Gameplay, was man gezeigt hat Leute, 25.10, aber wohlgemerkt
das war ja auch Prestige 15 Level 50 mit Zufallsklasse, also da, das musste man zeigen, egal wie schlecht,
egal wie schlecht das war, ah ja, und da könnt ihr euch vorstellen, wie sehr er das gegrindet
hat, der hat ja wieder, der Fabian hat ja damals auch schon wieder irgendwie 50 Accounts gehabt,
Januar, ok, Black Ops kam November raus, also sprich, das war ja nicht sein erster Account,
der hat ja immer tausende Accounts, ja, und, also der hat Prestige 15 Level 50 gegrindet
in ungefähr zwei Monaten, in ungefähr zwei Monaten und wahrscheinlich den Account innerhalb
von einem Monat, das ist schon ganz schön schnell gewesen, das ist schon ganz schön
schnell gewesen, guckt euch mal an, da sind Level 7 noch, Level 13, 11 und so dabei, kaum
Leute mit Prestige hier in der Lobby, kaum Leute mit Prestige, und der Fabian einfach
Prestige 15 Level 50, zu der damaligen Zeit haben wir wirklich fast Fulltime, wenn wir
nicht arbeiten gegangen sind, fast Fulltime Black Ops 1 gespielt, weil wir das Game so
geil gefunden haben, das, so siehts übrigens aus, wenn es kein Skill-based Matchmaking
gibt, dann wirst du hier als Prestige 15 Level 50 mit den Low-Bobs gematcht, ah ja, unglaublich
schon vier Jahre her, das ist mittlerweile, neun Jahre her, Poggers, oder wie der Franzose
sagen wird, Poggers, guck mal, neuste Comments hab ich, ah, Honey hab ich nicht, Alter ist
das Oldschool, Make Magne und Friseur great again, wie kann man ein Online-Game durchzocken,
ja, in dem Fall war das das einzige was zu anlocken gab noch, Prestige 15 Level 50, ist
er, ja genau, die Frage hab ich mich auch gerade gestellt, ist er, und das gleiche
hab ich vor vier Jahren schonmal drunter gepostet, ist er, ist er gar nicht, also eins muss man
echt sagen, der Fabian, der ist schon, also der Friseur war schon immer, immer so, klar,
der sieht jetzt ein bisschen älter aus, was ja auch nicht schwierig ist, das sah ja gefühlt
zehn Jahre lang aus wie 20, aber ansonsten, hat sich da wenig geändert, ok, also fangen
wir mal an, was ist das erste Video was wir uns anschauen, also das gucken wir uns nicht
an, da fand ich den Titel so beknackt, 60 Days Billionaire, ich glaube nicht, dass ein
Millionär dieses Haus in Auftrag gegeben hat, ist das nicht ein Twitch-Streamer, aber das
ist nicht der Twitch-Streamer, der heißt einfach nur ähnlich, Shitstorm für VW-Spot,
aber den Spot hab ich gesehen, den VW-Spot hab ich gesehen, ich habe die Aufregung wieder
nur zum Teil nachvollziehen können über diesen VW-Spot, habt ihr den VW-Spot mal gesehen,
da wurde wieder so krass viel reininterpretiert, da wurde so extrem viel wieder reininterpretiert
wie wenn der Tag lang ist, wo ich mir echter Kopf gegriffen habe, ich bin ein bisschen
lustig, sehe ich auch so, also es gab vielleicht von 20 Sachen die da angeführt wurden, ein
zwei Sachen wo ich gesagt hab, ok mit sehr viel gutem Willen könnte man da was reininterpretieren,
aber der Rest war echt, da war doch Bill Gates aktuell an allem schuld, Tesla Truck, was
soll ich mir mit einem Tesla Truck angucken, was Cyber Truck, was denn, was genau, was haben
die denn gemacht wieder, ich weiß jetzt nicht was ich mir da angucken soll, das ist die
Präsentation von dem Ding wo er gegen die Scheibe gehauen hat und die Scheibe ist kaputt
gegangen, das haben wir doch schon, das haben wir glaube ich sogar damals geguckt, das ist
ja schon ein halb Jahr her, ja aber nur mal für die Leute die diesen VW-Spot nicht gesehen
haben, VW, VW-Spot, irgendwie zwar hier Racist-Spot, aber wenn, also ich mein wenn uns das schon
die Bild erklärt, wenn uns das schon die Bild erklärt, da weiß man Bescheid, da weiß
man Bescheid, die Bild, die Bild, ok, ok, Leute, wir müssen es uns jetzt echt mal geben,
ich sag euch, zieht euch teilweise den Aluhut auf was da für Dinge sich an den Haaren beigezogen
werden, mal ab hier, aber wenn es schon die Bild erklärt, das sagt schon alles, wie da
spricht, da spricht fast ein bisschen wie der Semper-Video-Typ oder, der betont, der
Semper-Video-Mann, ich weiß nicht wie er heißt, betont auch immer alles so korrekt.
Ein dunkelhäutiger Mann wird von einer weißen Hand herumgeschubst, die User schreiben dazu,
in der neuen Werbung wird rein zufällig ein schwarzer Mann von einer weißen Hand hin und
her geschubst.
Hey Volkswagen.
Das tut so weh, das tut so weh, Alter, jetzt gehen wir mal vom umgedrehten Fall aus, jetzt
gehen wir mal vom, wir gehen jetzt einfach mal vom umgedrehten Fall aus, die Hand wäre
schwarz und der Mann wäre weiß, so, würde sich da auch jemand drüber aufregen, aber
ganz davon abgesehen, wäre der Mann weiß und die Hand weiß, oder der, oder gar sogar
der Mann Asiate und es wäre eine Asiatische Hand, ja meine Güte.
User schreiben dazu, in der neuen Werbung wird rein zufällig ein schwarzer Mann von
einer weißen Hand hin und her geschubst.
Hey Volkswagen, kurze Frage, warum macht ihr eine solch rassistische Werbung?
Für mich ist das Wegschnipsen eines Menschen wie Dreck oder ein Insekten ein mögliches
...
Das ist wirklich so weit hergeholt, ey.
Das, das ist, ähm, das ist so weit hergeholt.
Skandal.
Der dunkelhäutige Mann wird ins Restaurant Petit Coulomb geschubst, übersetzt heißt
dies kleiner Siedler.
Mal ganz davon abgesehen, ich könnte mir vorstellen, das Restaurant heißt halt echt so, das Restaurant
wird halt einfach so heißen.
Die User sehen eine Anspielung auf den Kolonialismus und dann auch zufällig...
Ich mein ja, man kann, man kann das sicherlich da alles rein interpretieren, ja.
Ähm, ja war mal komisch.
... in den Petit Coulomb reinspickt, weil ja Kolonialismus wahnsinnig viel mit Autos verkaufen
zu tun hat, so im Jahr 2020.
Wie kann das alles zusammen aber keine Absicht sein, allein schon diese schwarze Person ins
Hotel Petit Coulomb schubsen?
Die Hand im Video bietet beim Schnipsen das Zeichen für White Power...
Ernsthaft jetzt?
Ich, ich stelle es mir sehr schwierig vor, ich stelle es mir äußerst schwierig vor,
eine Schnipsbewegung zu machen.
Macht mal eine Schnipsbewegung mit der Hand, ohne, ohne, ohne euren Finger so zu machen.
Da erscheint doch jetzt garantiert noch mehr.
Okay, der neue Golf!
Okay, oh das ist so weit hergeholt, Alter!
Weder noch, weder noch, ich gehe weder davon aus, dass es Absicht ist, noch dass es ein
Missverständnis ist, sondern dass das, na doch, Missverständnis trifft es doch am ehesten,
dass das eine mit dem anderen überhaupt nichts zu tun hat.
Ich meine, du könntest da bestimmt auch 20 Zusammenhänge zu Osama Bin Laden rein dichten,
wenn du willst.
Da gab es doch, da gab es doch mal diese Vergleichsliste so nach dem Motto, äh, Osama Bin Laden ist
am gleichen Tag geboren wie Osamas Bodyguard und sowas in der Richtung, ähm, da könntest
du jedem ex-beliebigen Thema da irgendwas rein interpretieren, zumal, zumal die Bild,
jetzt wenn du auch nicht dafür bekannt bist, ähm, die Sachen möglichst objektiv zu berichten
immer.
Schämt euch!
Die Leute sind so schnell getriggert durch alles mittlerweile, meine Güte, äh!
Ne, weil das wahrscheinlich keinem, der nicht schon diese Einstellung von Anfang an vertritt,
aufgefallen wäre.
Also, wenn man diese, wenn man quasi schon die Einstellung hat, überall sowas sehen
zu wollen, dann sieht man es auch, aber wenn man die nicht hat, glaube ich, fällt das
einfach nicht auf.
Und wahrscheinlich wäre das 95% der Leute nicht aufgefallen, dass man das dort rein
interpretieren könnte.
Auf der anderen Seite, wenn es den Alphanod darum geht, dass, ähm, ihr Werbespot im Gespräch
ist, dann haben sie es gut gemacht, weil aktuell hat zu dem Zeitpunkt die halbe, halb Deutschland
über den Werbespot gesprochen, was ein normaler Werbespot, äh, was heißt normal, das ist
ja eigentlich ein normaler Werbespot, nicht, nicht gemacht hätte, ja.
Oh Mann, also da haben sie auch wieder eine riesen, eine riesen Welle gemacht.
Naja, gut, was auch immer, aber gerade, dass gerade die Bild, dass, äh, uns erklären
muss.
Ja, ich hab's mir aufgeschrieben, wenn das immer noch Donnerstag, 22 Uhr ist, dann,
vielleicht, ja, wahrscheinlich hab ich vor.
Wo ich ja froh bin, weil wir gerade bei so einem etwas kontroversen Thema sind, wo
ich ja froh bin, wo ich jetzt nur mal kurz sag, dass die, dass auf Twitch sich wieder
mittlerweile alle auf, äh, abgeregt haben, wegen, ähm, ich muss jetzt gucken, dass ich,
dass ich das richtig sage, wegen, ich sag's einfach nur wegen dem Reh, dass ich alle
wegen dem Reh abgeregt hab, da bin ich ja froh mittlerweile, da haben sie sich ja eine
Woche über das, äh, ausgekotzt, alle, allesamt, ja, und man muss ja auch sagen, das Reh hat
es auch angefeuert, ja, mit, mit Videos, also oftmals gehören da auch zwei Seiten dazu.
Na, ich zeig das jetzt nicht im Stream, Leute, da geht, da geht's wieder los, wenn, wenn
ihr wissen wollt, was sag ich, sucht einfach Twitch dir, Twitch-Council dir, dann, dann,
dann wisst er Bescheid, ja, ähm, Bambi, nee, nicht Bambi, das ist das Reh, ähm, aber
die hat's auch, äh, die hat es ja auch ein bisschen angefeuert, muss man sagen, also
es gibt ja Videos von ihrem Channel, wo sie hat gesagt, ja, ich hab jetzt die Macht über
euch und solche Dinge, wo man sich halt denkt, ähm, es ist in der Situation, wenn da eh
schon drüber diskutiert wird, nicht so sinnvoll, noch Öl ins Feuer zu gießen.
Zumindest Twitch hat sich wieder glücklicherweise abgeregt, das Reh interessiert wieder keinen
mehr.
Sind wieder zum normalen Tagesgeschäft übergegangen.
Das ist mit, ja, das ist die mit Voice-Chat, dass Voice-Chat ja irgendwie rassistisch wäre
oder so, was auch immer, äh, grad, ey, dieses Thema, ich kanns, ich kanns, eigentlich kann
ichs nicht mehr hören, eigentlich kann ichs nicht mehr hören, weil, weil, egal, in welche
Richtung die Themen gehen, da nicht mehr mit, mit normalem Maßstab rangegangen wird, sondern
überall gleich immer das Schlimmste vermutet wird.
So, also, was gucken wir uns jetzt mal schönes an.
Es wird ja immer schlimmer, okay, was haben wir denn hier auf, also, wir haben, wir haben
ein Video von, von Levelcap, mal gucken, was der erzählt hat, Life Service Games have a
big problem.
Die Überschriften von Levelcap sind immer zu vage, wo du denkst, oh, jetzt kommt was,
und dann erzählt er 10 Minuten was, wo du denkst, ah ja, okay, das ist halt nix Neues,
aber, hm, Meinung zu Skriptkitties, ich weiß nicht, ich, also, ich kenn den Channel nicht,
ich weiß nicht, was er erzählt, aber so Hexor-Themen guck ich mir immer mal ganz gerne an, geb
auch mal nen Senf zu, dann haben wir noch ein Video, AngryGermanKid, wie Focus TV ein Leben
ruiniert hat, das wird mich tatsächlich mal interessieren, weil das AngryGermanKid hat
ja mittlerweile seinen eigenen Hip-Hop-Channel auf YouTube, und ich glaub, hier, er, hier,
der ist das, und der ist, glaube ich, denke ich mal halbwegs erfolgreich sogar, ja, da
ist er am Start, hm, okay, aber kein, keine Ahnung, zumindest war das der Zeit, wo die
sich schon gerne, äh, generell aufgeregt haben, also, so, zu dieser Zeit, wo auch das
AngryGermanKid am Start war, das war so die Zeit, wo dann ARD auch Killerspiel-Beiträge
gebracht hat und sowas, ähm, er war leider, leider muss man sagen, der echte Gangster,
der war ein paar Jahre zu früh, genau Tribulle, er war seiner, er war seiner Zeit voraus,
er war seiner Zeit voraus, wäre der, keine Ahnung, drei, vier Jahre später am Start
gewesen, der hätte nen riesen YouTube-Channel gehabt, also wollen wir das gucken, okay,
ich will Unreal Tournament spielen, ne, ich will nicht, dass es lädt, oder so war das
doch, ja, alles nur gestellt, das war die gleiche Zeit, das war die gleiche Zeit, wo
der Assi-Tony am Start war, das war so ungefähr die gleiche Zeit, es gab das AngryGermanKid,
der hat ja noch mehr, der echte Gangster, was willst du tun, ähm, Unreal Tournament
spielen, ich will nicht, dass es lädt, der hat ja ein paar Sachen gemacht, der hat ja
ein paar Videos, und zur gleichen Zeit war auch der Assi-Tony schon am Start, ich weiß
gar nicht, ob's YouTube damals schon gegeben hat, oder ob man das, ich glaub, YouTube gab's
damals noch gar nicht, ähm, ähm, kennst du noch Videoamt, euer, da hab ich nie verstanden,
warum man das guckt, das ist halt alles gestellt, das ist halt alles gestellt, das ist halt
alles ge-
aber auch als el niño loco alemán, Japan als keyboard crusher, den keyboard crusher,
das gibt unzählige Versionen mit FakeSubs und die wildesten Remixes,
und obwohl das Meme fast 15 Jahre alt ist, gibt es immer noch Kanäle wie diesen, auf
dem bis heute regelmäßig neue, weirde Abenteuer des AngryGermanKid hochgeladen werden,
na gut, es gibt bis heute, es gibt bis heute ja auch diese, diese, diese zig dinger Hitler-Reacts,
ja, die habt ihr bestimmt alle schonmal gesehen, diese Szene im Bunker mit Untertiteln, ähm,
die halt aus deutscher Sicht nicht lustig sind, weil man versteht, was die Leute sagen.
Das detailliertes Fandom-Wiki zum AGK, an dem täglich, nee, stündlich gearbeitet wird,
heute geht es um einen jungen, kreativen Kopf, um eine reißerische, verlogene Focus TV Doku,
um übles Mobbing und um eine krasse Transformation zum Herkules.
Bevor es losgeht über das AngryGermanKid, gibt es bereits einige Videos auf YouTube.
Checkt insbesondere mal das des englischsprachigen YouTubers WavyWebsurf ab.
2006 läuft ein ehemaliger Schüler der Geschwister-Scholl-Realschule in Amstetten-Ammok, der Täter hat gewalthaltige
Computerspiele gespielt, anstatt sich auf unbeantwortete Hilfen zu machen.
Darauf sind sie dann alle auf Counter-Strike und so abgegangen.
Counter-Strike war schuld.
Es ist natürlich verlockend, nach schockierenden, grausamen Amokläufen mit den Fingern auf
Amstetten-Ammok zu machen, aber es geht um den Täter darum, was er für ein Typ war.
Es gibt eine psychologische Analyse, der Täter hat seine Schule als spielbare Counter-Strike-Map
nachgebracht.
Jetzt wird eine ganz fantastische Brücke geschlagen, im Wortlaut geht es über düsterer
Musik und Ballerspiele, die fokustv geht der Spur nach, was macht dieser via Internet genutzte
Schund mit einem, man besucht einen Klan.
Man besucht einen Klan, gespielt wird zuerst Warcraft 3, ballern bis die Aliens kommen.
Der Spieler braucht dann noch eine Adrenalin.
Quake?
Was wird gestartet?
Qube?
Hat man das damals gespielt?
Ach, das ist Sauerbraten.
Ja klar, das kenne ich, aber zu der Zeit hat man eher Quake 3 gespielt oder Unreal Tournament,
weil er will ja Unreal Tournament spielen.
Nach einem kurzen Besuch beim Spiele-Entwickler schaut man sich das damals europaweit einzige
Zentrum für Computerspiel-Abhängige in Amsterdam an.
Die Jugendlichen kommen aus ganz Europa, um sich hier von ihrer krankhaften Leidenschaft
für Ballerspiele zu befreien.
Das gab es?
So was gibt es wirklich?
Eines Jugendlichen, der andere Patienten bestohlen hat und dann mit dem Geld die ganze Nacht
in einem Internetcafé gezockt hat.
Diesen Superduper-Ultra-Gaming-Junkie hat Focus TV via herausragende Recherche auswendig
gemacht.
Alter, was die für einen Shit erzählen, was die für einen kompletten Schwachsinn erzählen
und es so hinstellen, als wäre das so.
Das ist heftig, oder?
Und wenn man das sieht, fragt man sich, wie viel Wahrheitsgehalt ist in anderen Berichten
so drin?
Wie tragisch, das Angry German Kid war eigentlich ein Ballerspiel-Junkie, das Video ist gar
nicht witzig, sondern traurig und schockierend.
Naja, wenn Focus TV sich die ganze Story nicht eiskalt ausgedacht hätte, der Junge
aus dem Video heißt überhaupt nicht Leopold.
Das ist nur der Name seines fiktiven Charakters Leopold Slick aka der legendäre Gangster.
Ich bin ein echter Gangster, ich höre Techno.
Der Junge hinter L to the P to the Slick war einfach ein Internet-Comedian.
Schon bevor es YouTube gab, hat er kleine Clips von sich im Internet veröffentlicht.
So was würde heute auf TikTok immer noch steil gehen.
Videos fand man z.B. auf lokalen Seiten wie lustig.de.
Außerdem hatte er einen Blog auf hodenmums.net.
Laut einem ausführlichen Artikel von Weiss zu dem Thema war der Junge hinter Slick sogar
einer der Betreiber der Seite.
Der echte Gangster war demnach eine Parodie des Frankfurter Rappers GPC aka Schneemann.
Hab ich schon nie gehört.
Hier ein Ausschnitt seines Mixtapes aus dem Jahr 2004.
Ich bin ein echter Gangster, ich fahre Auto ohne Gur.
Schneemann ist der Mikrofon.
Was willst du tun?
Oh, das ist ja nur...
Das ist ja...
Also...
Das ist ja schlechter als die Verarschung.
Das Angry German Kid war Deutschlands vielleicht erster großer Troll seiner Zeit um Jahre
voraus.
Ja, das stimmt.
Genau das.
Der echte Gangster wurde nach dem ersten Video zu seinem Charakter, der diverse Dinge erlebt
hat.
Der Originaltitel des Ausrastervideos ist ECHTER GANGSTER 5 PC SPIELEN und stammt aus dem Jahr
2005.
Zu diesem Zeitpunkt wird YouTube populär und der Ausraster verbreitet sich via Internet
wie ein Lauffeuer auf der Plattform, weit über irgendwelche Foren hinweg.
Das Schauspiel in PC Spielen ist so gut, plus die versteckte Kamera, dass Leute einfach
nicht verstehen, dass es nur ein Witz ist.
Das Video geht viral.
Hier beginnt für den echten Menschen...
Und das ist oftmals das Problem, weil es gibt unglaublich viel dumme Leute auf der
Welt, die keinerlei Gespür haben für subtile Sachen in Dingen, die es einfach nicht erkennen
können.
Es ist aus dem Zusammenhang gerissen, vielleicht auch ein bisschen schwierig zu erkennen, dass
es gestellt ist, aber ich glaube jeder, der noch ein bisschen normal im Kopf tickt, wird
zumindest Zweifel daran hegen, ob das Video legit ist.
Also jeder, der das das erste Mal sieht und ein bisschen, ein bisschen, wie nennt man
das, keine Ahnung, so emotionale Kompetenz, ein bisschen Feinfühligkeit aufweist, der
wird zumindest überlegen, das Video könnte gestellt sein, aber die meisten Leute sind
einfach dumm, das hatten wir ja schon oft und die checken das nicht.
Hinter Leopold legt ein Albtraum.
Er wird in der Schule gemobbt.
Auf dem Schulhof schreien ihm irgendwelche Schüler hinterher und machen ungefragt Fotos
von ihm.
Er ist damals 14 und gibt fünf TV-Sendungen Einwilligung, sein Video zu zeigen.
Wie das endet, wissen wir.
Seine Comedy wird zum Beweismittel in einer reißerischen Doku, die auch mithilfe seines
Videos suggeriert, zwischen Spielsucht, Ego-Shootern und Tragödien, wie dem Amoklauf von Imstetten,
gäbe es eindeutige Zusammenhänge.
Slick reagiert wie ein Champ und macht sich über die Doku lustig.
Hallo Freunde, mein Name ist Leopold, ich war mal spielsüchtig, doch dann hab ich eine
Therapie in Amsterdam gemacht.
Er versucht klarzustellen, dass der Ausraster nur gespielt wird.
Aber die Leute checken es nicht.
Aber es ist zu spät.
Die Leute checken es nicht.
Die Doku macht für ihn alles noch viel, viel schlimmer.
Die Leute glauben ihm zum Teil einfach nicht mehr, dass der Ausraster nur gestellt sei.
Wie kann man das nicht glauben?
Das ist so dumm.
Das ist so offensichtlich.
der, wie es damals für ihn gelaufen ist.
Das Mobbing hält jahrelang an.
Er färbt seine Haare schwarz, trägt Militärstiefel und Kontaktlinsen,
um abschreckend zu wirken und damit ihn niemand erkennt.
Irgendwann rastet er auf einer Klassenfahrt aus.
Er googelt ein Bild eines Maschinengewehrs
und zeigt es seinen Klassenkameraden.
Das hier hab ich zu Hause rumliegen, im Darknet gekauft.
Ein Klassenkamerad filmt alles und zeigt es einem Lehrer.
Der Teenager hinter der Kunstfigur fliegt von der Schule.
Er will keine Sozialstunden machen
und hat kein Geld, um eine Geldstrafe zu zahlen.
Sieht man wieder, wie unfähig die meisten Lehrer sind.
Deshalb geht er für einen Monat ins Gefängnis.
Anschließend fällt er... Wofür?
Moment. Wofür?
Wofür ist er in... Warum?
Für was?
Ich mein, der hat ja das Gewehr wahrscheinlich gar nicht gehabt.
Alter...
Keinen Ausbildungsplatz und keinen Arbeitsplatz.
Überall wird er als verrückter Fast-Amokläufer
oder als Unreal-Tournament-Kind abgestempelt.
Er isoliert sich und fängt an, richtig heftig pumpen zu gehen.
Auf dem Kanal Kochan91 findet man einige Videos aus dieser Zeit.
Die sind jetzt auf dem Kanal.
Voll das Tier, ey.
Nach zwei Jahren findet er endlich eine Ausbildung.
Neue Freunde und eine Freundin.
Man erkennt ihn auch wirklich nicht. Das stimmt schon.
Um 180 Grad.
Unter dem Namen Hercules AGK baut er heute Beats und rappt.
Die Geschichte des Angry German Kid ist unglaublich.
Ein normaler Junge mit Schauspieltalent,
aber sogar zu viel.
Humor, für den Deutschland noch nicht bereit war.
Ein viraler Hit.
Zu viel Fame und erschreckend rücksichtslose Berichterstattung.
Focus TV hat uns gegenüber keine Stellung bezogen.
Die Doku wird immerhin schon seit Jahren
nicht mehr im Fernsehen ausgestrahlt.
Eins ist klar.
Focus TV-Reportagen zeigen echte Menschen,
spannende Geschichten und wahre Emotionen.
Wir geben ihnen den Hut vor der Legende.
Dem echten, wahrhaftigen, nicht unterzukriegenden Gangster.
Leopold Slick.
Cheers.
Gutes Video.
Und dass er sich durch die ganze Sache durchgekämpft hat.
Mein persönlicher Held des Tages.
Da kann man echt nur sagen, Hut ab.
Der richtig echte, originale Gangster.
Genau.
Der war einfach seinerzeit voraus.
Jetzt den Asi-Ton.
Oh, nee, das kann ich nicht im Stream gucken.
Also, aber ich muss sagen, so mein persönliches Highlight-Office,
das ist das, was ich in meinem Video gemacht habe.
Das ist das, was ich in meinem Video gemacht habe.
Aber ich muss sagen, so mein persönliches Highlight
aus dem Video war trotzdem...
War trotzdem...
Man besucht einen Clan.
Gespielt wird zuerst Warcraft 3.
Ballern, bis die Aliens kommen.
Das ist so dumm.
Ich kenne das ja noch von damals.
Ich habe das wieder voll verdrängt.
Aber das ist so unglaublich dämlich.
Warcraft 3.
Ballern, bis die Aliens kommen.
Es ist so abgrundtief dumm einfach.
Ich weiß gar nicht, was ich dazu sagen soll.
Doch, ich weiß, was ich dazu sagen kann.
Moment.
Das ist das Einzige, was man dazu sagen kann.
Ich weiß gar nicht, was ich dazu sagen kann.
Doch, ich weiß, was ich dazu sagen kann.
Moment.
Das ist das Einzige, was man dazu sagen kann.
Christian Pfeiffer kam ein bisschen später.
Der war zu der Zeit, glaube ich, noch wenig am Start.
Der kam erst so 2008, 2009, 10 rum.
Okay.
Das haben wir als nächstes.
Top Battlefield Play...
Warum habe ich denn...
Warum habe ich denn Merkels Botschaft zu Corona auf?
Das will ich jetzt nicht gucken.
We made the slowest PC.
Ein Tag im Leben eines Software-Entwicklers.
Meinung zu Skriptkiddies.
Okay, dann machen wir das jetzt mal.
Wie gesagt, Channel, Video, keine Ahnung.
Aber ich gebe da gerne meinen Zelt immer dazu.
Skriptkiddies sind in Anführungsstrichen Hacker.
Die Ausschüsse der vorgefertigten Skripte und Tools zurückgreifen,
um Ziele anzugreifen.
Sie besitzen oft kaum bis keine Fachkenntnisse...
Vor allem sind es Schwätze hoch 10.
Die sich gerne darstellen als eine richtig krasse Überhacker-Man.
... nutzen Hacking zur Selbstdarstellung oder um Mutrienschaden anzurichten.
Ich möchte dir in diesem Video mitteilen,
was ich von Skriptkiddies halte
und warum ich ihr Verhalten in bestimmten Fällen unterstützen würde.
Wenn du schon länger im IT-Umfeld arbeitest und deine Anfangszeit schon einige Jahre zurückliegt,
dann würdest du dir vermutlich schwerfallen zu verstehen,
warum Personen auf vorgefertigte Skripte zurückgreifen,
und sich nicht einfach selber welche schreiben.
Ich lade dich an dieser Stelle dazu.
Mach ich heute auch noch.
Warum sollte man alles selbst programmieren?
... an die Zeit zurückzuerinnern, in der du deine ersten G-Versuche in der Programmierung unternommen hast.
Als ich mit dem Programmieren angefangen habe,
konnte ich selbstverständlich auch noch keine Skripte...
Warte, ist es PHP?
Ist es JavaScript?
Ist es...
Nee, ist es PHP, oder?
Ist es PHP?
Das ist, glaube ich, PHP.
PHP Pros.
Was ist das?
...
Cobol.
Nein, Python, das ist garantiert nicht.
PHP. Also ich würde sagen, das sieht am ehesten PHP aus.
Was mich an PHP erinnert, ist einmal hier dieses,
dieses, this mit Dollar.
Das generell war, wie am mit Dollar sind.
Array, das sieht sehr, es könnte auch,
es könnte auch Perl sein, es könnte auch Perl sein,
aber Perl sieht ein bisschen anders aus.
Array Multisort.
Das sieht, das sieht sehr nach PHP aus,
diese Funktion.
Na gut.
... ganze Anwendungen bauen.
Ich habe mich vor meinen Rechner gesetzt, Webseiten besucht...
Das rechte ist JavaScript, ne?
... und dann in den Dateien nach Informationen gesucht,
die mir dabei helfen zu verstehen, wieso ich im Browser das sehe,
was ich sehe.
Ich habe dann begonnen, einzelne Bestandteile in den Dateien zu
modifizieren, zu löschen oder neu hinzuzufügen.
So bekam ich Schritt für Schritt ein Gefühl dafür,
wie die Sprache des Webs funktioniert.
...
Immer dann, wenn ich ein eigenes, kleines Webprojekt
umsetzen wollte, habe ich nicht alles
vom Scratch komplett neu gebaut,
sondern auf bereits vorhandene Bausteine zurückgegriffen
und diese angepasst.
Macht mich das automatisch zu einem Script Kiddy?
Vielleicht.
Das hängt von der genauen Definition ab.
Ganz einfach abgesehen, warum selbst programmieren,
wenn man Stack Overflow copypasten kann?
...
nicht wissen, wie sie funktionieren.
Mit der Zeit lernt man durch diesen Copy-Modify-Paste-Ansatz sehr viel über die generische Struktur
des Programmierens kennen, was Kontrollstrukturen sind, wie man IF-Anweisungen verwendet und
so weiter.
Oh!
Exzellent!
Wenigstens mal einer der IF-Anweisungen sagt.
Ich kriege immer Anfälle, wenn es der letzte Azubi macht.
Der letzte Azubi hat es auch Anfang des Jahres hier und da war.
Hat es auch gemacht.
Und es ist weit verbreitet, dass die Leute sagen, IF-Schleife.
Kennt ihr das?
Wenn die Leute sagen, IF-Schleife.
Es ergibt überhaupt keinen Sinn, eine IF-Schleife, aber es gibt so viele Leute, die sagen das.
Wenn es gibt sogar eine Seite-IF-Schleife, wirklich?
Nein, gibt es nicht.
Hätte mich jetzt aber nicht gewundert, wenn es das gibt.
Also ich sage meistens einfach nur IF.
Und in dem Fall vollkommen korrekt, es ist IF-Anweisungen, es sind ja alles irgendwo
Anweisungen.
Man kann auch sagen, IF-Entscheidung kann man auch sagen.
Man kann eigentlich fast alles sagen, außer IF-Schleife.
Der Zeit sein Wissen in der Web dadurch nach und nach die Fähigkeit, sich an die eigenständige
Entwicklung zu begeben.
Portale wie Stack Overflow sind aber natürlich nicht umsonst so beliebten der Entwickler-Community.
Auch erfahrene Programmierer nutzen die Seite, um gemeinsam mit anderen an ihren Problemen
zu arbeiten, anderen zu helfen oder Lösungen für bekannte Probleme zu adaptieren.
Auch das ist in meinen Augen alles andere als verwerflich.
Selbst Anony bekommt man bei Programmieraufgaben gesagt, dass es erlaubt ist, bestimmte Teile
seines Scouts aus dem Internet zu entziehen, sofern man bei hinreichender Schöpfungsrude
Quelle benennt.
Ein einfacher Ballett.
Es ist ja auch absolut weltfremd, das nicht zu tun.
Es zählt beispielsweise nicht dazu.
In meinem Video, in dem ich der Frage nachgehe, wie man Hacker wird, erwähne ich unter anderem
auch, dass man viel im IT-Umfeld ausprobieren und sich in einer größeren Community austauschen
muss.
Es kommt vor allem darauf an, ein sehr breit gefächertes Wissen aufzubauen.
Und genau darin unterscheidet sich meiner Ansicht nach ein Skripti-Cognominate-Hack.
Kannst du ein bisschen lauter machen?
Ist doch eigentlich, oder?
Passt doch?
Also einem Hacker in Ausbildung.
Okay.
Ich kann ein bisschen.
Ich kann ein bisschen lauter machen.
... in einer größeren Community austauschen muss.
Es kommt vor allem darauf an, ein sehr breit gefächertes Wissen aufzubauen.
Und genau darin unterscheidet sich meiner Ansicht nach ein Skript-Kitty von einem Greenhead-Hacker,
also einem Hacker in Ausbildung.
Das Skript-Kitty stagniert in dem Stadium des Ausprobieren von Skripten, während Greenheads
vorgefällt, Skripte dazu zu nutzen.
Schöne Mützchen.
Gibt's die denn auch mit Alu?
Um aus ihnen zu lernen und das Wissen daraus in anderen Bereichen anzuwenden.
Es ist ein Geben und Nehmen.
Wenn man von jemandem etwas gelernt hat, hilft man einem anderen entweder mit genau diesem
erwordenden Wissen oder mit etwas anderem, was man selbst gut beherrscht.
Man ist nicht gleich ein Skript-Kitty, wenn man nachschaut, wie man im Python eine Netzwerkverbindung
zu einem Server aufbaut oder wenn man eine Funktion kopiert, die eine Tabelle mit den
Ergebnissen der Anwendung verschiedener Hashe-Funktionen auf einen String enthält.
Wenn man hingegen ein Letos-Skript kopiert, dieses anwendet und nicht einmal weiß, was
genau im Hintergrund abläuft, dann ist das eigentlich mehr als peinlich.
Unter Umständen macht man sich eigentlich sogar strafbar, ohne es zu wissen, weil man
auch keine Zeit in das Studium der entsprechenden Rechtsgrundlagen, wie etwa den Hacker-Paragraphen
ausnimmt.
Das ist den Leuten doch egal, ob das peinlich ist oder nicht, die wollen damit irgendwas
bezwecken.
Entweder wollen sie sich als super krassen Hacker-Mann darstellen oder so wollen wirklich
irgendwelche Leute im, was weiß ich, Facet-Matchmaking-Dedossen oder so.
Ganz davon abgesehen, oftmals ist es gar nicht so easy, also in Form von, wir laden uns
einfach den DDoS-Skript runter und dann geht das auch so ohne weiteres.
Ich habe in letzter Zeit vermehrt die Anfrage bekommen, ob ich die Skripte, die ich in meinen
Videos entwickle, nicht auch als Exit zur Verfügung stellen kann und am besten noch
so, dass man das zum Beispiel zum Hacken aller Instagram-Accounts anwenden kann, anhand
solcher Fragen sieht man bereits, dass die entsprechenden Benutzer weder den Sinn meines
Beitrags noch die Technik dahinter verstanden haben.
In solchen Fällen würde ich ganz klar von einem Skriptkiddy sprechen.
Es gibt aber auch Benutzer, bei denen man merkt, dass sie sich wirklich mit dem Thema
auseinandergesetzt haben und durch Rückfragen versuchen, weitere Informationen, zum Beispiel
den Aufbau von Rainbow-Tables zu erhalten, obwohl es in dem Video beispielsweise um einen
einfachen Brute-Force-Angreifen bei- Wer braucht Rainbow-Tables, wenn er schnell tippen
kann?
Zudem bringt ein Greenhead-Hacker eigene Ideen mit, wenn vorhandenes Skript erweckt
in ihm den Wunsch, es zu verbessern und weiterzuentwickeln.
Wenn sich ein Greenhead zum Beispiel das Python-Projekt Sherlock anschaut, dann wird er mit dem Funktionsumfang
höchstwahrscheinlich unzufrieden sein und versuchen, weitere Funktionen einzubauen.
By the way, möchte jemand erklärt bekommen, was Rainbow-Tables sind oder soll ich einfach
weitermachen?
Mit Sherlock kann man für einen bestimmten Benutzernamen diverse öffentliche Profile
automatisiert sammeln lassen und dass all diese Informationen im Sinne der Open-Source-Intelligent
Information über einen Target erfahren.
Allerdings gibt es aber nicht nur einen, sondern gleich viele Haken.
Einer davon ist beispielsweise, dass ein gefundenes Profil manuell dahingehend überprüft
werden muss, was tatsächlich zu dem Target gehört.
Auch prüft Sherlock nur direkt auf den Benutzernamen und nicht auf mögliche Variationen dieses
Benutzernamens.
Der Benutzer Alex Müller könnte in einem anderen Portal zum Beispiel Alexander Müller
heißen.
Ein Skriptidi würde sich über den limitierten Funktionsumfang freuen, während ein Greenhead-Hacker
das Projekt vermutlich ausbauen würde, wozu ein Skriptidi wahrscheinlich noch nicht mal
in der Lage oder zu faul ist.
Und wenn man zu einem Fazit kommt, ich finde es nicht verwerflich, wenn man sich in seiner
Anfangszeit vorgefältigte Programme nimmt und schrittweise versucht, diesen nachzuvollziehen.
Auch ist es nicht notwendig, bei jedem seiner Projekte das Rad immer wieder aufs Neue neu
zu erfinden.
Wenn man allerdings nur auf Anerkennung oder Schabernack aus ist, sich nicht mit der Theorie
hinter einer bestimmten Angriffstechnik auseinandersetzt und keine Ambition hat, tiefergehendes Wissen
aufzubauen, dann gehört man meiner Ansicht nach zu dem klassischen Skriptidi.
Da sind wir Greenhead-Freitauslieber.
Jeder Greenhead fängt irgendwo mal als Skriptidi an, doch das Mindset, was man direkt zu
Beginn mitbringt, unterscheidet ihn dann doch von einem Skriptidi gemäß der allgemein
anerkannten Definition.
Vielen Dank fürs Zusehen.
Solltest du weitere Fragen haben, kannst du sie gerne unten in den Kommentaren posten.
Ich finde auch schön, dass er das Wort Schabernack verwendet hat.
Excellent.
Bis zum nächsten Video.
Ja, kann ich voll und ganz zustimmen.
Also, ganz kurz, was eine Rainbow-Table ist, das ist eine Zuordnung, Klartext zu Hash
vor einem speziellen Hash-Algorithmus, also sagen wir mal MD5-Summe, MD5-Hash-Werte,
man nimmt sich ganz viele Texte, Input, hasht die und speichert sich den Output, das heißt,
man kann dann ziemlich einfach erkennen, wenn man einen Hash sieht, welcher Klartext dazu
passt, also vorberechnet quasi.
Das geht natürlich nur in einem bestimmten Ausmaß, weil sehr, sehr viel Input notwendig
ist.
Und spätestens, wenn man anfängt mit Random-Faktoren, wie das dann in Salt dabei ist, der Salt ist
übrigens bei Hashes genau deswegen vorhanden, dass man es nicht im Vorfeld quasi ausrechnen
kann, so Tabellen, weil das sich je nach Salt unterscheidet und man dann quasi diese Tabelle
für jeden Salt nochmal bräuchte.
Ja, aber ganz grob gesagt kann man sagen, das ist einfach eine vorberechnete Tabelle
von Input zu Hash-Wert mit einem speziellen Hash-Algorithmus, was da rauskommt.
So, was haben wir als nächstes, kommen wir gucken jetzt Battlefield-Top-Plays an, wird
mal wieder Zeit, Battlefield-Top-Plays, haben wir schon eine Weile nicht mehr geguckt.
Moment, mach gleich wieder von vorne an, ja der Ausstärke passt, what the fuck, ich hab
nicht hingeguckt, auf einmal fliegt da ein Panzer, only in Battlefield, das war geil,
jetzt muss ich noch mal gucken, Battlefield-Physics, Battlefield-Physics, Battlefield-Physics,
Battlefield-Physics, nach fliegt der Panzer jetzt noch mal, come on, come on baby, yes,
yes, oh fuck yes, got the, yes, got him, yes, got the chopper.
Oh, erstmal den Jet auf den Kopf gehauen, was ist das für eine Map, oah, Poggers, nice
Roadkill, locker, lass mich raten, die meisten Clips sind locker und Metro, eventuell noch
Sand-Crossing, wenn sie Battlefield 3 zeigen, leih, oh, hätte das funktioniert, das wäre
nice gewesen, ah, weggesprayt, so muss das sein, genau.
Pokelaser, ich hab ja, ich hab ihn ins Sub-Gegiftet bekommen.
Oh nice, nice, das muss ich mir nochmal angucken, ich hab's nicht alles genau gerade gecheckt.
Oah, nice, man hat Glück, dass sie da alles doof rum eiern, aber das kommt nicht oft
vor, haha, ist das jetzt sein Ernst, excellent subscription hier.
Dankeschön für den versteckten Subs, Zola, Zolaire von Astora, jetzt bin ich ja froh,
dass Pokeman endlich den Wubbler aus Sub hat, was sehe ich da, ist das ein Commander-Top-Play,
ich hab noch nie einen Commander-Top-Play gesehen, was sehen wir da überhaupt gerade,
es ist ein Commander-Top-Play, das hab ich ja noch nie gesehen, sollte der Commander-Mode
nicht auf dem Handy funktionieren, ja, das sollte doch sogar auf dem Tablet gehen, ja,
da rein, hier, Achtung, BÄÄÄM, oah, wieviel waren das jetzt, 10, hab ich da noch nicht
gesehen, ich hab noch nie einen Commander-Top-Play gesehen, ich muss euch ehrlich sagen, ich
weiß, dass der Commander-Mode ein paar Hardcore-Fans hat, aber ich brauch ihn nicht unbedingt
in einem Battlefield, ich find ihn jetzt nicht so wahnsinnig essentiell, was war das denn
jetzt gerade, ah, Bazaar, der hat einen komischen Farbfilter drüber, sieht fast aus wie aus
der Matrix mit dem grünen, oah, gefühlt ist jeder von Instant Gaming gesponsort, ich nicht,
aber ich war lang genug von G2A gesponsort und ich hab keinen Bock mehr auf Key-Shops,
ja Taze, ich mein, viel größer geht's ja auch nicht als an Streamer, na, das ist also
das obere Ende der Fahnenstange, also ich hab von G2A, weiß gar nicht mehr, was ich
von G2A gekriegt hab, ich glaub 1000€ im Monat, ich glaub 1000€ im Monat fest und
Affiliate obendrauf, so in dem Dreh, ich hab's irgendwann mal erzählt, wieviel's genau
waren, da hab ich nachgeguckt und da wusste ich's auch noch besser, ich glaube so 1000€
in dem Dreh war anders, glaube, äh, RealRenax hat aufgepasst, er sagt, es waren 800 plus
pro Vision also 1000, ok, dann war das so, wie gesagt, ich weiß nicht mehr genau, ähm,
das würde mich auch nicht wundern, Tribolon sagt gerade Montana Black hat wohl nen Festvertrag
mit Twitch beziehungsweise Bezahlung, unabhängig der subs, das würde mich nicht wundern, allein
schon aus dem Grund, dass er nicht einfach zu einer anderen Plattform gehen kann, da
wird Twitch schon nen Auge drauf haben und ich geh davon aus, dass viele der Aushängeschilder
von Twitch das haben, das kürze ich nen extra Vertrag, dass sie nicht einfach die Plattform
wechseln können, äh, warum bist du von G2A weg, weil sie genervt haben, ich war ja verpflichtet
so und so viele Sachen zu machen im Monat und, ähm, die ging halt immer auf den Sack,
ich hab noch nicht ein Placement bisher auf Twitch gemacht, habe ich auch nicht vor, aber
man weiß ja nie, wenn jetzt morgen einer eine Mail schreibt, sagt Max hier Ultra Angebot,
wir wollten schon immer mal deinen 228 Zuschauern hier unseren neuesten, äh, Programming Energy
Drink, äh, erzählen, dann excellent, dann mach ich das, ich hab gesagt auf Twitch hab
ich noch nie welche gemacht, auf Youtube schon, auf Twitch noch nie, alter die werden jetzt
ganz schön weggesprayt hier mit der AIK, ich mein die spawnen ja dahinten, die spawnen
ja hier rechts drinnen, rechts ist hier das spawn, übrigens das leerste Gebäude und
sinnloseste Gebäude in ganz Battlefield 3 hier hinten in der Ecke, ähm, und das ist
schon halber spawn rate, aber die Maps sieht man relativ selten,
erstmal schon eingesmoked, in Rush war das Gebäude das letzte M-Com, nee,
in Rush lag das M-Com vorne im Gebäude, also ein Gebäude war da vorne und am Bus, das
M-Com war in der Pizzeria oder was das war, oder im Eisladen unten, wir haben immer gesagt
in Pizzeria, aber ich weiß gar nicht, wie es einen offiziellen Callout für gibt, hallo,
Battlefield 4, das kann sein, Battlefield 4 Rush hab ich nie in Metro gespielt glaube,
der hat den AD-AD-Spam aber auch komplett im Tuss oder, der ist nur am AD-AD laufen,
oh wie sie sich wegsprayen lassen, huge, bisschen komische Farbe hier, ne, so gelb
irgendwie, Sounds waren in fast allen Battlefields gut, man muss ja auch sagen, dass sogar in
Battlefield 1 und 5 die Sounds gut sind, Sounds können sie, das ist wirklich poggers, wobei
mir persönlich, Bad Company 2 mit War Tapes war mein persönliches Highlight, was Sound
angeht in einem Game, ich hab die Map nicht einmal gespielt, keine Ahnung, ja, das war,
ich muss auch sagen, Gunplay mäßig hat mir Hardline auch ganz gut gefallen, die Maps
waren teilweise richtig räudig, diese Bungalow, ne nicht Bungalow, diese Häuser Map, ich
weiß gar nicht wie sie heißt, diese, wo einfach nur Häuser hingesetzt wurden in einem Rechteck
im Endeffekt, die war richtig beschissen, was mir persönlich in Hardline gefehlt hat,
waren, vielleicht bis auf Conquest, der klassische Battlefield Modus, war sowas wie Rush ein richtig
guter Spielmodus, den ich gerne durchgesuchtet hätte, und Heist, Heist fand ich übelst dumm,
die Runden waren entweder total schnell vorbei oder teilweise auch richtig vercampt, Heist
hat mir nicht gefallen, vor allem weil es immer nur eine Station war und dann mit dem
Abhauen, also ich glaube ein ordentlicher Rush Modus wäre cool gewesen und Blood Money
war voll für den Arsch, die Hitboxen sind aber sehr großzügig
gerade, das haben sie original einfach übernommen aus Battlefield 3, inklusive Visier und Waffe
und Sounds, Locker, was sonst, was ist das P90, Ah nee Tar, Poggers,
Locker, wer hätte das gedacht, Gegner maximal Lost, ja immer,
immer, immer, immer.
Oh, da checken sie nix und kriegen von der Seite rein gesprayt
Mit der Waffe habe ich immer gespielt das war meine absolute Lieblingswaffe in Battlefield 4
Beste
Finishing off today, we've got two pretty hast du momentan einen egoschütter die die ganze spielst. Ja ich spiele relativ viel warzone gerade
Wobei ich sagen muss das spiel hat auch seine problemchen. Ja
Es hat halt es hat halt den modern warfare multiplayer komplett gerettet der modern warfare multiplayer ist einfach absoluter
Bodensatz warzone macht es ganz erträglich
Leider es ist halt vor allem in solo duo extrem verkämmt
Und teilweise auch richtig random und ich mag an sich battle royale spiele nicht
weil
Weil mir zu wenig passiert schlicht und angreifend ja also wenn du am ende von der runde warzone 8 9 kills hast
Dann war das schon mehr oder weniger also in trio oder kurz
Dann haben wir im prinzip haben dann hat man insgesamt hat man 30 30 kills oder so
Über alle leute verteilt und dann war das schon permanent action im endeffekt
Man darf sich nicht. So sehr jebaiten lassen durch die ganzen world record gameplays und sonst was da war das schon quasi permanent action im sinne von
von battle royale spielen
und
Oftmals liegt man halt auch einfach mal fünf minuten naja gut das jetzt übertrieben in warzone nicht aber
Zwei drei minuten passiert halt gar nichts dann passiert irgendwas damit man unglücklich vielleicht nur weggekämpft weil irgendwer im haus sitzt
Ja apex gefällt mir ein vom zugucken auch besser also battle royale ist
Battle royale ist nicht. So meins auch nachdem ich jetzt eine ganze ecke warzone gespielt habe
Für mich ist battlefield rush der perfekte modus macht mir am meisten bock das ist genau die richtige abwechslung aus high intense
feuergefecht und dann quasi
Gucken dass man gute laufwege erwischt und dann wenn man gute laufwege erwischt hat auch gleich belohnt werden weil man schon von
der seite acht leute wegspringen kann für mich ist hat rasch die perfekte dynamik und ist mein lieblingsspiel modus über alle games hinweg
Natürlich natürlich in einem ordentlichen battlefield mit ordentlichen maps
Possibly the best form that i've seen he spawns in in a really difficult position, aber wie das schön über die bande die granate geschmissen hat okay war überhaupt nichts
Gegner sind wir da komplett brain afk
shotgun
combination this thing is absolutely deadly in close quarters locker is the perfect map for it die sind so
inkonsistent in battle field die shotguns
mal schießt sie über die halbe map heute kaputt und mal ist da vor dir und er stirbt nicht
Allerdings meistens klappt
Foggers
Thanks for watching this episode of the battlefield top plays if you did enjoy you can leave a like down below if you didn't feel
Free to leave a dislike. Hopefully you've got some clips if you have you can send them into battlefield top plays
schönes video guckst du immer gerne am either by google drive dropbox or another file sharing system or close quarter battle 43 war auch gut
Ja, thanks for watching. I'll catch you in the next episode
Sehr nice
so
Zahmen wir sonst noch mal gucken was uns youtube jetzt vorschlägt wir müssen immer zwischendurch mal gucken ob es da irgendwas interessantes gibt
Tor versus vpn
Hey, das ist fast fast ähnlich zu dem
Zu dem video was ich auch mal gemacht habe bei mir ist das irgendwie vpn es lohnen sich nicht oder sowas
Aber ähnliches ähnliches thema
Triggerwarnung
Also, wie sieht es eigentlich mit andocken aus
Keiner nicht großartig
So was will ich nicht bauen 30 meter auf 60 quatratmetern
2020 sowas will ich nicht bauen 30 meter auf 60 quatratmetern what the fuck
Ja
Okay, der hat zu viel zeit
Ach du scheiße ach du scheiße
Boah
Aber wohl
Ich setze gerade wirklich so vor dem rechner
Also das trifft mein gesichtsausdruck gerade ungefähr also sehr sehr genau
Da hast aber was zu tun da hast
Ach du scheiße da hast aber was zu tun
Ach du scheiße da hast aber was zu tun da hast aber was zu tun
Ah
Oh
Okay das ging gut ab das ging gut ab
Okay
Okay, irgendwie total sinnlos aber trotzdem nice
Nice
Eigentlich komplett sinnlos
Warum es keine giraffen gibt ist mir ehrlich gesagt wurscht
Was empfiehlt uns youtube denn noch
Wie viele views hat das was ist das denn
What the fuck
Was denn das ist das wenn du dir deine finger gebrochen hast dass du dann auch um rechner arbeiten kannst oder wie
Aber das ist ein interessantes videos kommen wir uns gleich mal antrieb wollen wie viele
Was kriegen wir da gerade alles vorgeschlagen 14 millionen easy
Der channel hat selbst 2,6 millionen subscriber also es war auch für den ziemlich erfolgreich was ist das
Sie sieht ein bisschen aus wie warli am anfang oder es minimal
Komm was kann seitlich fahren huge konstruktion
Weil die musik dabei
Ja was ich mich frage ist ist das ferngesteuert oder hat das programmiert dass es exakt ausgemessen ist wie es fahren muss und wann es was macht
Oder sind das gar irgendwelche sensoren drinne die quasi linien am boden erkennen oder so
Oh Monkeys
Penetration
Es sieht echt ziemlich komplex aus
Okay wo wir wieder beim thema sind ergibt überhaupt keinen sinn aber ist irgendwie cool
Guck mal das fährt sogar unten aus je nachdem wie viel drauf ist
Cool
Was die hustle back potato das ist eine andere sorte
Zubereitungs art die wird nicht komplett durchgeschnitten die wird nur eingeritzt
Ja den rubik's jub solver den haben wir uns glaube ich schon mal angeguckt
Das ding was irgendwie in 1,2 sekunden das ding rumdreht
Da kommt die wurst mit der wir die wusste die wusste mit reingefahren
Die wird auch aufgespießt die maschine kann halt nur aufspießen
Okay das funktioniert jetzt nicht 100 prozentig sie wird eher abgedrückt am ende
Aber eine coole idee ist es trotzdem es ist komplett sinnlos ja aber es ist cool
Irgendwie finde ich es geil kann auch nicht so genau erklären warum richtige aufschneider
Komm wie ordentlich das verlegt das ist eine coole das ist eine coole subscriber idee
Die katze die futtert wahrscheinlich die wurst
Also die idee ist cool bringen tut es nix baut er nur so dinge
Ein einschneidendes erlebnis
Wie wie wie poggers oder poggers würde ich das wahrscheinlich ausspringen
Französischer poggers
Boah das ist ja geil
Huge
Guck mal hier
Ich mein das ist wahrscheinlich so vermehlt und staub nach ner halben stunde das es nicht
mal funktioniert und es ist auch komplett sinnlos im endeffekt aber das ist geil dass
das geht
Per hand wäre man natürlich schneller
Guck mal es wird sogar belegt
Das ist mein big brain
Das ist ja geil
Das würde ich sogar essen
Also hacklo wenn du die richtige einlädst finde ich das auch cool
Das brot ist ein bisschen dick das stimmt
Aber es wäre halt unglaublich viel aufwendiger gewesen das dünner zu schneiden weil er hätte
quasi das doppelt so groß oder doppelt so groß viel enger machen müssen mit den lego
teilen zum schneiden das hätte nicht funktioniert
Wäre halt die frage wie das wie hykönig der chat ist schon wieder richtig next level
an sachen wo kein mensch dran denkt
Das ist sicherlich nicht sondern nicht hygienisch das kannst du das kannst du sauber machen
und dann kannst du ein baguette wahrscheinlich mit machen und dann hast du in allen ritzen
was drinnen hängen
red pepper
Oder wie die oder die was ich bei den bbq pitboys immer toll finde wie sie paprika
aussprechen
Übrigens weil ich so viele französischen flanken sehen tapas ist glaube ich spanisch
pitmaster privilege
irgendwie ist das geil ich kann es nicht genau erklären warum das wird sogar abgeholt guckt
euch das man
Okay das würde ich essen bier trinken würde ich nicht
Ich mag kein bier
Was ein geiler channel der muss man gleich mal bookmarken da können wir öfters da können
wir echt öfters mal was von gucken das ist einfach nice
warum hat es nur 55.000 views sowas sowas hätte ich jetzt gedacht hat 155.000
fruit fruit plate factory
new intel tentacle monster
keine tentacle monster hier
firewood
er wird es ähnlich sägen wie das baguette
halt nur ein bisschen langsamer
und halt sehr trockenes holz und weiches holz
wie sie alle wie sie alle hier immer noch auf battlefield 5 am rüberhaken sind
zurecht zurecht wohlgemerkt
was macht denn spacex gerade
im schnee
ja guckt euch mal die die hölzer an
damit kannst du nicht viel heizen
und nicht viel kochen
ja die sind angemalt das ist kein echtes kein echter baubstamm
das ist halt sehr trockenes sehr weiches holz und wahrscheinlich würde die relativ langsam
dann durchschneiden
guckt mal hier da kommt die säge
genau das richtige tempo
genau das richtige tempo hier
aber guck mal guck mal wie gut das funktioniert
ich bin begeistert
wie gut das funktioniert
schon das ist schon ziemlich pock
jetzt bräuchte er nur noch was was er so pustet
dass dass dass die die säge dass das staub da abgeht
sägespäne genau
oder ein sauger guck mal die hydraulik da hinten
ich glaube da bist eine weile dran bis sowas konstruiert hast
ja das ist klar das ist bemalt das gefärbtes das ist geholt das ist kein kein echter ast
moin nox 2702
guck mal hier sogar mit greifarmen
oh oh jetzt wird es horizontal äh vertikal noch noch gesplittet
mit der rasierklinge
die hält aber da nicht lang
kommt das oben davon runter
das kommt runter durch das nächste was hinterher fährt
das nächste fährt hinterher und schmeißt das vordere runter
das heißt man verliert man verliert zwei stück vom letzten vom letzten stück
scheint schon gut kraft zu entwickeln das plastik klar
es gibt auch das video wo der eine 100 kilo hochhebt mit einem lego motor
allerdings mit einer metallachse
also ich finde schon dass es so aussieht als könnte das funktionieren
guck mal das wird sogar abtransportiert dann
kannst du auch einen kleinen wagen ziehen klar
theoretisch kannst du mit jedem motor alles ziehen
also du kannst auch du kannst auch mit einem lego motor wenn du stabil genüge teile hast
natürlich äh könntest du auch den lkw ziehen
ist gar kein problem ist immer nur die frage in welcher zeit
wenn du eine woche wenn du eine woche für einen zentimeter brauchst kannst du das damit
auch machen aber das ist halt dann nicht sonderlich
sinnvoll
ich wusste keine ahnung dass das archimedes gesagt hat
aber archimedes war ja nur nachweislich excellent
massif brain war archimedes der mit der mit der mit der
badewanne oder präge ich das jetzt durch ne das war ein anderer oder
wer war das mit der badewanne das war archimedes oder
den war das archimedes
welcher grieche war dann das mit der badewanne der festgestellte dass sein körper das wasser
in der badewanne verdrängt
die griechen hatten so viel big brain leute da kannst du die leute gar nicht alle merken
galileo nein nein nein nein das war das das das könnte wirklich archimedes gewesen sein
so so genug lego zeug gekauft was war was macht was macht spacex
ok dann hat er schon mehr gemacht als ich heute
dann gucken wir jetzt wo wir gerade schon bei big brain leuten sind dann gucken wir uns
jetzt mal an
ein tag im leben eines software entwicklers oder gucken wir mal
wie sehr das an meinem tag rankommt ich könnte wetten gar nicht
weil hat jeder so seine andere angeher rangehensweise ja aber 6 uhr aufstehen kommt schon mal hin
6 uhr aufstehen kommt schon mal hin ich stehe normalerweise 5 vor 45 auf aber zum glück
kann ich gerade
dank korona homeoffice machen und kann ich ein bisschen länger pennen
das muss ein bisschen lauter machen
1 stunde nach dem aufstehen nutze ich in der regel um an irgendwelchen eigenen projekten
anzuarbeiten
mache ich abends
oder ein video wie dieses zum beispiel
mache ich abends mache ich abends und zwar zum größten teil mittlerweile im stream sogar
die erste stunde nach dem aufstehen nutze ich in der regel um an irgendwelchen eigenen
projekten anzuarbeiten
irgendwelche apps
ich finde es toll dass der direkt aus dem bett kommt und angezogen ist
ein video wie dieses was sind das für eine tastatur
igitt wie kann man mit so einer tastatur arbeiten
egal nicht ich bin ja nicht dafür da jetzt immer die leute zu flamen obwohl ich sie nicht
kenne
ich stelle es nur aus meiner sicht mir merkwürdig vielleicht ist die tastatur richtig gut
ich sage gar nichts
was hat er denn da unten in livestream oder was da unten am start
ah nee der machte er machte ab der entwickelte telefon ab unten sieht er die vorschau von
der app
die musik ist so laut fitness
fitness ok ja ok unser tag fängt schon mal naja so unterschiedlich ist das gar nicht
also ich mache es ja mittlerweile so ich fahre mit dem zug zum südbahnhof in frankfurt
und nicht zum hauptbahnhof und ich laufe ja vom südbahnhof ich meine ich fahre nicht
mit dem fahrrad aber
ich laufe immerhin eine halbe stunde morgens und halbe stunde mittags deswegen also laufen
nicht rennen laufen
ich fahre natürlich kein fahrrad das wäre besser für mich aber das mache ich nicht
zumindest bewege ich mich auch minimal morgens und nachmittags
ich habe gemerkt dass das einen riesen unterschied macht
von gar nicht bewegen zu ein bisschen bewegen
die musik ist voll laut
ist das frankfurt? es ist nicht frankfurt
in frankfurt würde man hier hinten die hochhäuser sehen eigentlich
hier so was ist denn das
irgendjemand eine ahnung was das ist münchen
münchen ist auch ein kopfbahnhof könnte sein ja
es könnte auch köln sein es ist auch ein kopfbahnhof
es könnte auch
war dresden ein kopfbahnhof ja dresden könnte es auch sein es ist ein kopfbahnhof
hinten ist die frauenkirche in dresden haben sie auch eine frauenkirche
münchen okay excellent münchen ist das alles klar
Leute ist die musik nicht zu laut?
viel zu laut
wenn ich ein morgenmensch bin dann lehne ich auch den sport am liebsten vor der arbeit
schon
aber das gesprochen ist dazu
dass wir ein fitnessstudio direkt bei uns im gebäude haben
und dort gehe ich dann erst mal eine stunde
fitnessstudio im gebäude das haben wir nicht
wir haben denn gesponsert das fitnessstudio das ist allerdings 45 minuten in die falsche
richtung da gehe ich nicht hin
wenn wir ein fitnessstudio im gebäude hätten
ich würde mir überlegen tatsächlich hinzugehen
ohne miss ja das wäre einfach poggers
im büro sitzen wir den ganzen tag deswegen finde ich super wichtig dass man ab und zu
ein bisschen sport treibt um einfach ein bisschen ausgleich zu schaffen
den rücken zu stabilisieren da gibt es so viele möglichkeiten einfach ein bisschen
was zu machen ist einfach super wichtig
ok also sound mixen müssen wir nochmal üben
das ist übelst anstrengend
ok das ist schonmal also sport am anfang
ich würde sagen die wenigsten leute die irgendwo in der IT arbeiten die ich kenne
vielleicht kenne ich einfach nur nicht die richtigen leute
machen morgens vor der arbeitssport aber gut
das würde mir viel morgens würde mir das viel zu viel zeit kosten
ich meine neun ne wie viel uhr geht da ins büro
neun uhr neun uhr ins büro so da bin ich schon eineinhalb
da bin ich schon da bin ich schon zwei stunden im büro fast
bin ich schon fast zwei stunden
wollen die sich umarmen oder da würde ich da würde ich anfälle kriegen weil mich leute
auf dabei umarmen wollen
geh fort
mit hund im büro mit hund im büro ist irgendein hipster laden
ich muss ich darf die leute nicht immer so flamen weil ich kenne sie alle gar nicht
vielleicht ist das komplett anders wie ich mir das vorstelle
der arbeitet bei payback ok payback
an dem projekt mit dem ich momentan beschäftigt bin arbeite ich und noch ein kollege
der kollege ist jetzt nicht mit mir hier zusammen in münchen
damit wir uns einfach zusammen absprechen haben wir eigentlich einmal am tag eine videokonferenz
und nur einfach mal kurz durchzusprechen wer heute was macht ob wir bei irgendetwas
hilfe brauchen einfach ein bisschen alignment zu haben
wisst ihr was cool wäre wenn man das einfach von daheim aus machen könnte wenn man schon
eh nicht mit dem typ leider ist das bei vielen firmen noch nicht standard ja
man könnte ohne probleme wenn die eh nur quasi an diesem projekt arbeiten an dem tag und
eh beide nicht im büro sind könnte man das auch von daheim machen
das wäre natürlich viel cooler was ich viel was ich viel äh ekliger finde
ist das setup
ok ich mein jeder wiederer mag jeder wiederer mag aber die tastatur ich weiß nicht ob die
wirklich so toll ist
und dann nur so ein kleiner bildschirm also ich ich würde ich wäre da nicht so happy
mit aber jeder wiederer mag ja
außerdem spiegelt das display as fuck vor allem notebook display mit mit lampe dahinter
und dann ein dark theme editor
das ist es sieht nicht so ergonomisch aus aber jeder wiederer mag ja
als halb für meine tagesplanung gehe ich noch mal meinen kalender durch um natürlich
auch zu schauen ob ich irgendwelche interviews hab normalerweise lade ich mir dann den cv
von den leuten runter um noch mal ein paar punkte aufzuschreiben
was
ähm interviews hab
ich hab den anfangs nicht verstanden
als halb für meine tagesplanung gehe ich noch mal meinen kalender durch um natürlich
auch zu schauen ob ich irgendwelche interviews hab
interviews
oh es ist es ist outlook sieht man sofort
es ist es ist outlook monkaS
haben wir leider auch
weise lade ich mir dann den cv von den leuten runter
aber aber es kann schlimmer kommen es kann schlimmer kommen es könnte lotus north sein
um noch mal ein paar punkte aufzuschreiben
sachen die ich noch mal gerne nachhaken möchte
ähm bestimmte fragen noch mal raussuchen für dieses bewerbungsgespräch
natürlich haben wir so ein paar standardfragen die wir immer fragen
ah er ist er ist bei der er ist bei einstellungsgesprächen dabei das heißt er ist auf jeden fall entweder
ist er zuhälfte personalmann das glaube ich aber nicht
sondern wahrscheinlich ist er einfach schon lange noch dabei
ähm dass sie ihn als technikmann mitnehmen zu vorstellungsgesprächen
aber natürlich muss man sich trotzdem noch mal auf den kandidaten noch mal spezifisch
vorbereiten weil natürlich nicht alle gleich sind
aber heute ist alles leer es sieht gut aus das heißt ich kann die ganze zeit eigentlich
mit dem coding verbringen
den scheiß muss man so oft machen obwohl es komplett in den selten fällen richtig
richtig umgesetzt wird
man sieht auch schon wie viel spaß die und wie viel lust die leute haben daran teilzunehmen
die haben schon richtig bock drauf die haben richtig bock drauf vor allem die leute mit
ihren noise cancelling bose kopfhörern mit der amstade
ähm zumindest also jeder jeder jeder coole laden hat sowas mittlerweile
einfach nur weil sie besonders agil aussehen wollen sorry
agile agile richtig agil aussehen wollen es wird leider selten richtig umgesetzt
es kann es kann funktionieren aber eigentlich nur wenn das moderiert ist
das kann nur funktionieren wenn es moderiert ist
ähm und am besten funktioniert es eigentlich wenn das leute sind die nicht übergreifend
arbeiten
sondern an an einem projekt dann kann das ganz gut funktionieren
leider macht man solche stand ups immer übergreifen
oder oftmals übergreifen also sprich er kommt aus einem anderen team
anderes team anderes team anderes team anderes team
ein anderes team so da wird dann morgens gewürfelt
wer muss heute hin ich habe mich aber ein paar unserer runden
die wir haben freiwillig gemeldet beispielsweise dienstags
dienstags haben wir immer so eine so eine wartungsarbeiten ankündigungs runde
da habe ich mich da habe ich sogar freiwillig gesagt da gehe ich hin
und das ist halt immer aneinander vorbei geredet im endeffekt
du hast bei diesen runden einmal leute die gehen hin und weil sie halt hingehen müssen
oder haben keinen bock oder was auch immer und stellen sich halt dabei
und du hast aber auf dieser runde auch oftmals leute die gerne sich erzählen hören
und so nach dem motto ok wer am meisten sagt der hat auch quasi der ist auch am wichtigsten
da hast du immer leute dabei was halt was halt richtig sagt bei solchen runden
wenn das gut moderiert ist dann geht das wenn man wirklich sagt
hey man beschränkt das dass das geht von 10 bis 10 auf 15
und jeder darf maximal zwei minuten was sagen und es ist ganz wichtig
meiner persönlichen meinung nach es ist ganz wichtig dass man etabliert in solchen runden
dass man etabliert dass es ok ist wenn man nichts zu sagen hat
versteht ihr was ich mein weil ansonsten ist es einfach so einen zwang wo jeder das
gefühl hat er müsste sich jetzt irgendwas aus den fingern saugen
er müsste jetzt irgendwas sagen obwohl es nichts zu sagen gibt
und ab dem punkt atmen diese runden in sinnloser in in sinnlosen schwanz vergleich im endeffekt
aus wer ist wichtiger und kann mehr sagen es muss etabliert werden also muss moderiert
sein und es muss etabliert werden dass alles so meiner meinung nach
dass es ok ist wenn man nichts wichtiges zu sagen hat man dann in diesen runden auch
nichts sagt und dass es nicht dann heißt im endeffekt
der sagt ja auf der runde nix der macht ja wohl nix
so das ist das ist halt schwierig egal gucken wir mal weiter
ja der hund denkt sich auch alter monka es
moment das sind ja noch viel mehr leute das waren ja nicht alle das waren ja das standen
ja 30 leute rum oder so okay da da da kommt da kommt nix bei rum
ich als kfz sehe gerade eine andere welt ja burning burning rabbit das ist so eine sache
das machen sie aktuell gerne vor allem vor allem alle die besonders agil und hipster
sein wollen die machen so so stand ups und wer richtig wer richtig geil sein will der
nennt das dann scrum weil es hat mit scrum nichts zu tun einfach
sich einmal zehn minuten im kreis zu stellen nichts gar nichts ja es ist vielleicht ein
prozent davon aber nennt es dann scrum weil es ist weil es sich weil es sich geil anhört
und die stonks leute freuen sich dann der marius bock
alex v den marius bock hat richtig bock oder war schlecht no happy meal for you ja ich
kann mir vorstellen dass es richtig dämlich war
water logic excellent big brain zum trinken quasi
kaffee mache ich nicht wir haben auch wir haben auch
nen kostenlosen kaffee kostenlose kaffee maschinen mehrere über das stockwerk verteilt
richtig gute teure also da haben sie sich wirklich nicht zurückgehalten was geld angeht
kann sie irgendwie zwölf verschiedene kaffeesachen machen und ich trinke halt kein kaffee für
mich ist es komplett useless aber ich finde es cool dass es das gibt
so ein softwareprojekt arbeitet man eigentlich relativ selten ganz alleine das stimmt damit
das projekt ist nicht in einem absoluten chaos versinkt und jeder macht was er will
war das eine war das eine gett history gerade war das gerade gett history was er gezeigt
arbeitet man eigentlich relativ selten ganz alleine damit das projekt ist moment da war
noch eben noch was dazwischen oder habe ich mich verguckt habe ich komplett verguckt
da war noch was dazwischen damit das projekt ist nicht in einem absoluten
hier das könnte eine kommet history sein nee nee ist es ist es eher könnte ist es aber
glaube ich eher nicht chaos versinkt und jeder macht was er will gibt es so genannte oh jetzt
hier war das in den kanban board oder so was das man kann man kann ja diese man kann ja
diese ganze planung noch viel weiter treiben kann band boards ist auch was sehr beliebtes
da in der richtung schon mal gesehen das ist eine jenkins pipeline oder so was ich erkenne
es nicht richtig irgendeine big brain death ops pipeline macht was er will gibt es so genannte
pull requests der damit wenigstens ein thema womit ich mich auskenne ganz grob erklärt ich
habe sozusagen eine kopie von dem projekt sieht aus okay das ist github ja sieht man ja auch
sieht man auch um ich dachte erst ein bisschen aus wie github aber also mit bucket ist es auf
keinen fall da passen die farben nicht aber github sieht auch mittlerweile ein bisschen
anders aus muss aber sieht man auch an der uhr dass es github ist ich kenne kennt ihr eine
firma die wirklich github für interne projekte verwendet also bei uns ist es bei uns ist nicht
so microsoft selbst vielleicht ja aber gerade mein source code in der cloud weiß nicht also
wir hatten früher github mittlerweile mit bucket weil policy weil atlasien beste laut unseren
stauns leuten okay wir gucken einfach weiter und ich mache dann meine änderungen darin und nur
diese änderungen werde ich anfragen dass es reingemerged wird also wieder zurück in das
mainprojekt und so ein pull request ist dann sozusagen genau die ganz schön umfangreicher
pull request zu dem was es jetzt im eigentlichen projekt ist meine kollegen und kolleginnen die
machen dann ihr review das heißt die schreiben dann ihre kommentare in diesem pull request rein und
ich überarbeite das ganze dann nochmal ihr seht ihr macht das gleiche wie ich ich mag den da macht
es gleiche wie ich in einem projekt an dem ich selber gerade privat arbeite weil ich euch jetzt
natürlich nicht den code von unserer payback abzeichnen kann ja mal kantine das kantine ist
top bin ich froh dass wir mittlerweile auch eine haben in welchen fällen nutzt man am besten
rebase statt merge man benutzt und man macht rebase eigentlich nur in privaten feature branches von
sich und am besten dann bevor man es zu mörchen einreicht du musst aber auch nicht rebasen du
kannst einfach resetten und cherry picken wenn du wenig comments hast was im prinzip eine rebase
für dich auch macht wenn die rebase zu magic ist okay es sieht jetzt nicht wahnsinnig gut aus
vielleicht schmeckt aber kantine im eigenen haus ist ein riesen vorteil ist massive poggers und am
besten noch wenn es ein bisschen subventioniert ist bei uns ist es ja insofern subventioniert
dass beispielsweise trinken kostenlos ist also normales trinken ist kostenlos und für ein euro
kannst du all you can drink fanta cola gedöns noch haben wenn man möchte und das essen an sich bei
uns in der kantine ist halt auch in anführungsstrichen relativ relativ günstig du zahlst irgendwie für
den mittagessen 5 6 euro mitten in frankfurt ist es natürlich top und du bist sofort da
du verschwendest keine zeit im endeffekt um hin und zurück zu laufen also mit sechs euro
beim mittagessen bist du ungefähr bei uns dabei das ist natürlich super meinst du die
mitarbeiter sammeln privat auch payback punkte bestimmt bestimmt die müssen ja testen ob ihr
kraft funktioniert ist spaziergang ich muss ja sagen für das dass es zwölf uhr ist er hat
bis jetzt relativ wenig programmiert oder jetzt geht es ab jetzt kommt der hacker mode
gezwungen ist per programming ist komplett für den arsch also wenn die wenn er zwungen
beide keinen bock drauf haben ist kacke ich finde es viel sinnvoller es ist wie gesagt ich kann
ja immer nur meine persönliche persönliche meinung zum besten geben ich finde es viel besser wenn
man einfach sagt hier ich kann auch mal einer mitgucken ob das so sind ob das sinnvoll ist was ich
gebastelt habe oder guckt man sich das mal kurz 10 15 minuten zusammen an und dann ist gut finde
ich viel viel angenehmer als da eine stunde zu zweit davor zu sitzen und zu basteln was ist
denn der eigentliche gedanke hinter per programming ich würde sagen der grundgedanke ist dass man
weniger fehler macht oder dass man das hat einfach noch permanent ein zweiter drauf guckt man sich
auch zu austauschen kann wie könnte man es besser machen was anders machen dass man weniger fehler
macht dass man vielleicht der eine was sagt was man noch nicht weiß man ihm was sagt was er noch
nicht weiß dass man auch ein bisschen was lernt an sich finde ich ist es ein guter gedanke aber
also erzwungen finde ich doof ist nicht mein fall ich finde ich finde es viel angenehmer wenn beide
leute auf dem stand sind und sagen hey was wir programmieren ist nicht perfekt oder was wir
machen oder was wir skript oder egal generell was wir halt machen ist nicht perfekt und wenn
ich mir nicht sicher bin frage ich halt mal jemand anderes sage ich hier kann es mal kurz mitgucken
und da kommt ein anderer vorbei wir gucken uns das 10 minuten an und gut ist finde ich finde ich
viel angenehmer als ja also aber das geschmackssache
macht das relax bis denn
die programmieren so wenig ok ich sag's ja auch immer das meiste wenn man programmiert ist nicht
text tippen an sich sondern gucken wie es geht und gucken wie man es macht auch motivation in
persona wie es der hat wie es ein ordentliches setup der hat wenigstens ordentlich in den halbwegs
ordentliches setup notebook davor der hat einen hochkanten bildschirm auch nicht schlecht und
und noch hier oben im bildschirm das erkennt man wenigstens was das ist bestimmt dass das ist
doch das ist das apple zeugs hier ist das apple kram richtig schöne old school telefone haben
wir auch unsere telefone sehen aus als könnte sein damit erschlagen so ein bisschen wie die hier
und da hat auch die richtige programmierhaltung so geht das übrigens großraumbüro das ist ja das
ist ja alles großraumbüro hier sieht man ja ich finde gerade großraumbüros ist epic fail für
softwareentwicklung es sei denn man möchte den ganzen tag ein neues canceling kopfhörer aufsetzen
auf auf den kopf haben ja ist klar ist klar ist klar ok vielleicht vielleicht wirklich vielleicht
macht das wirklich so ich kann ich kann auf jeden fall so nicht richtig programmieren so
nicht richtig denken aber jeder ist jeder ist anders in der richtung nachmittag
wisst ihr was ich nachmittags mache gehe ich heim wie viel uhr ist es
wann hast du arbeitszeiten naja ich ich kann mir das eigentlich relativ frei einteilen ich
arbeite meistens von 7 bis 15 30 wie viel uhr wie viel uhr am anfang hatte immer die uhrzeit
eingeplänt das fand ich voll interessant wann was ist
der arbeit kümmere ich mich natürlich noch um dinge wie einkaufen gehen und kochen und so weiter
aber auch abends nutze ich gern noch die zeit um ein bisschen rum zu basteln ich habe momentan
noch besser besser auch noch dem nächsten video dazu rausbringen das könnte auch ganz interessant
für euch sein und auch ganz gerne mal ein bisschen playstation spielen aber das weiß
es eigentlich von so einem ganz normalen tag also wie gesagt also abends sitze ich dann auch
noch hier und filme zum beispiel den abspann von dem video hier ich hoffe ich habe ich mit dem
video ist ja einen ganz guten einblick geben können wie so ein tag top top pulley beste
konsole ever normalerweise aussieht natürlich je nachdem was für eine art von software
wickelung man macht sieht es überall ein bisschen unterschiedlich aus das ist nicht überall das
gleiche aber das ist jetzt so bei mir ein ganz normaler tag gewesen weil sie noch irgendwelche
fragen habt dann auf jeden fall unten die kommentarfunktion benutzen cooles video
verpassen ich freue mich bis zum nächsten mal euer kevin cooles video auch wenn ich
zwischendurch ich kann ja nichts angucken oder nicht ein bisschen zu flamen aber nachdem jeder
ein bisschen ein bisschen anders ist wie ihr es gerne hätte also ich könnte nicht programmieren
auf dem sofa liegend großraumbüros finde ich auch ziemlich er fail gerade für eine für für
hauptsächlich software entwicklung aber ja okay mein ist halt so wie es ist bei denen
ja der kommentar welcher habe ich nicht gesehen ganz ja ich kann einen stuhl empfehlen gf xod
aber da ist viel zu teuer den würde ich aus der preisleistungsmäßig niemals empfehlen der
ist gut der stuhl den ich habe aber das viel zu teuer den würde ich kaufen ansonsten kann ich
dir leider kein empfehlen nur dass ich mir den dx racer vor ein paar jahren gekauft habe und
der kaputt gegangen ist ich die x racer echt kacke finde mittlerweile er war weder großartig
bequem noch war qualitativ gut welly date scheint nicht so der richtige methoden namen zu sein
wo warum nicht welly date besser bester methoden warum war was stimmt da dran nicht der guckt ob
eine mack adresse eine echte in der richtigen mack adresse ist oder wie oder verstehe ich jetzt
nicht was ist an was ist daran so schlimm
hä war falsch geschrieben ach hier unten weil die da tate ok da habe ich gar nicht
darauf geguckt jetzt meine kunde das hat das war so offensichtlich dass das payback ist
ok nur drei punkte also ich weiß ja nicht wie was für krasse software hier bummer
ambar entwickelt aber normalerweise muss man nicht permanent architektur und requirements
machen wenn man ein projekt wenn projekt läuft ich mein muss man an welchem projekt in der
größten ordnung muss man dann wirklich den ganzen tag dann noch architektur und requirements
machen wenn man sich das mal gut durchdacht hat ich mein klar es ist nie es ist nie unwichtig
es ist nie vorbei in dem sinn dass man sich über neuerungen architektur gedanken machen
muss was für anforderungen sonst was aber wenn man was startet vor allem während leuten
dran dran bastelt dann ist es am anfang schon ein bisschen hin und her aber wenn es dann
erst mal läuft dann wird schon zum größten teil programmiert ich meine das ding muss
ja irgendwann mal fertig werden das muss ja irgendwann mal fertig werden wenn er den
ganzen tag dann nur noch an architektur und requirements rum also dem requirements requirements
ist eine sache das muss ja gerade mal vor allem am anfang geklärt werden was es eigentlich
machen soll ob es da ist und was auch immer also ich meine irgendwer muss es programmieren
das frage ich mich tatsächlich auch ja aber wie gesagt jeden wie es gefühlt gefällt
ich sag ja auch nicht es muss jeder den e3 wm verwenden unter linux kann jeder machen
wie er will aber also die meisten bei uns sind mittlerweile
auch früh da es ist viel angenehmer gerade wenn ich jetzt auch noch ein bisschen youtube
fühle ich jetzt mal nicht als beispiel aber gerade seitdem ich in letzter zeit so viel
live stream es ist einfach viel besser ich bin früh fertig weil was bringt es denn wenn
ich 17 uhr erst anfangen heimzugehen und dann irgendwie um 19 uhr gerade mal mit allem
hier fertig bin und dann um 21 uhr anfangen zu streamen für eine stunde oder für zwei
stunden das ist komplett für den arsch bringt doch nix ja so wie hier dargestellt ist es
aber in den meisten firmen nicht wirklich aber das video fand ich gut gemacht also
gefilmt war das wirklich sehr nice das soundtrack war ein bisschen laut programmierer mit einem
mech warum nicht die machen irgendwelche web anwendungen ist doch vollkommen egal womit
man die macht und gerade nachdem das ja so ein bisschen hipster laden ist natürlich
hinter max voll angesagt ja das stimmt das hat mich auch gewundert
trotzdem alles in allem echt nice video hat bestimmt eine weile gedauert das zu schnippeln
was macht eigentlich space x gerade die fliegen rum und alle mit corona mundschutz seht
ihr das das ist richtig wenn man ios beziehungsweise
weg anwendung programmiert bleibt hier nix anderes übrig außer mac os zu verwenden die
sind schon angekommen ich glaube die kommen erst um 15 uhr an
denn die haben noch nicht angedockt ja sie sind noch nicht angedockt ok was haben wir
sonst auch so schön ist zu bieten ihr videos live service games have a big problem aber
level cap bin ich in letzter zeit so ein bisschen skeptisch bei den videos da steht immer sonst
was riesiges im titel und am ende erzählen was was man eh schon weiß wie möchte slow
sprint new pc sowas was empfiehlt uns youtube da noch
what is happening i will ich will einfach nur die katze sehen
die denkt sich auch was hat der zweibeiner da wieder für komischen kram hingestellt
eins können katzen ja echt gut kritisch gucken ich glaube es gibt kein lebewesen was es besser
schafft kritisch zu gucken alles katz die kritisch gucken können sie einfach so gut
so was macht der da wieder für den schwachsinn meine kommt auch immer so kritisch x hudi
ne x hud fragen hallo max ich hätte gern eine eigene cloud worauf ich meine worauf
ich mir alle geräte moment was langsam max lesen deutsch skills ok alex ohne fehrer
gucken wir gleich hallo max ich hätte gerne eine eigene cloud worauf ich mir alle geräte
drauf zu worauf ich mir worauf ich mit allen geräten darauf zugreifen kann google drive
dropbox möchte ich nicht hören hast du einen tipp was meinst du mit zugreifen willst du
kalenders dünken mails to do's termine dateien was willst du machen
größtenteils dateien also wenn du die ganzen funktionen nicht brauchst die dir zum beispiel
next cloud bietet dann also das ist eine option aber wenn du wirklich nur dateien
sinken willst kann man sich darüber streiten ob sie beste ist dann probieren mal also wenn
du die ganzen kram hier nicht brauchst was sie noch haben irgendwelche kalenders online
editor geschichten kontakte sind wenn es hauptsächlich um dateien geht dann probieren
mal das da aus reine synchronisierung ist das echt nicht verkehrt man sieht ja auch
mit 31.000 github sternen ist das keine software die irgendwie wenig verbreitet wäre sondern
ziemlich beliebt ist halt nicht mit next cloud zu vergleichen das spricht du hast da kein
web interface mit editor und alle möglichen drinnen sondern rein für die datei sink ist
das ziemlich gut ansonsten wenn du ein bisschen mehr features haben willst wenn du web interface
haben willst mit sich sachen vielleicht auch wo du mails angucken kannst oder kontakte
sinken kannst was auch immer dann ist next cloud eigentlich das beste allerdings next
cloud ist so genauso wie on cloud so ein bisschen das so unpolished irgendwie 85 prozent geht
ziemlich gut next cloud einfach weil dort mehr entwicklung passiert aktuell als bei
on cloud da geht es einfach schneller vorwärts das problem an next cloud finde ich immer
beim benutzen ist 85 prozent funktionieren ganz gut aber vieles wirkt so kantig und unpolished
irgendwie oder denkst du irgendwie hakt das so und macht keinen spaß zu verwenden manchmal
würde ich mir würde ich würde ich würde ich mir so wünschen dass die bei gerade bei
next cloud dass die vielleicht weniger darauf schielen würden jetzt immer mehr sachen einzubauen
in form von video konferenz geschichten haben sie jetzt eingebaut und sonst was sondern
darauf gucken dass man wirklich das web interface ist ja der große verkauf selling point so
mit von next cloud dass man das ordentlich polished macht ok gucken wir uns mal das
game star video an half life alex ohne vr es funktioniert ist zum kotzen ja ich würde
es auch nie ohne vr spielen das ist der grund warum ich mir vielleicht sogar eine vr prelle
kaufe nein und nicht wegen vr porn sondern deswegen half life alex ist ein fantastisches
spiel aber die einstiegshürde ist nicht allzu gering man braucht nämlich ein vr gerät
das muss nicht unbedingt das teuerste sein aber so billig sind selbst die preiswertesten
nicht inzwischen gibt es aber eine möglichkeit das neue werf spiel auch ohne vr geräte zu
spielen würde ich gerne sagen aber ob das wirklich schon spielen in verbindung mit
spaß ist vielleicht eine andere frage wie das funktioniert und wie gut es funktioniert
also ob man sich half life vr ohne vr kaufen und auch genießen kann das kann uns mein
kollege michael obermeier beantworten denn er wahrscheinlich gar nicht mich du hast
kopfschmerzen ja das das beschreibt es schon ganz gut also mir dröhnt jetzt ganz schön
der schädel und die ganze zeit während diesem unterfangen das auszuprobieren ist mir dieses
jurassic park zitaten hier aus dem kopf gegangen die wissenschaftler waren so damit beschäftigt
zu überlegen ob sie etwas tun können dass sie niemand überlegt hat ob er das auch tun
sollte denn kann half life alex tatsächlich jetzt mit auf einem pc ohne vr headset spielen
die große frage ist aber sollte man das wirklich tun wir müssen eingangs glaube ich ein paar
sachen klarstellen also zunächst mal zu meiner person ich möchte jetzt hier nicht als der
vr snob abgestempelt werden der jetzt hier sich über alle erhebt und alle runter macht
die das jetzt ohne vr headset spielen wollen ja habe alex ist mit einem vr headset ein
großartiges erlebnis ich kann das jedem nur empfehlen der das die möglichkeit dazu hat
aber ich verstehe auch wie du eigentlich schon gesagt hast das kostet einen haufen geld
ja das da bin ich nämlich auch überlegen ob ich mir wirklich nur für diese eine sache
in den vr headset kaufen sollte so wirklich viele vr spiele gibt es ja nicht das resident
die jetzt ist das neue resident evil verhören es lohnt sich noch aber ansonsten es gibt
schon ein paar aber es ist weit davon entfernt jetzt irgendwie ein umfangreicher katalog
zu sein abseits von half life alex auch nicht so viele gute argumente die auf dem gleichen
niveau sind dass man sich so eine teure brille kaufen kann also ich verstehe durchaus diesen
drang man will das spiel quasi jetzt ohne vr headset spielen und dazu gibt es diverse
möglichkeiten was zum beispiel eine möglichkeit ist es gibt einen developer version eine frühere
version von half life alex die man dann so spielen kann wie half life 2 also quasi einfach
durchlaufen das gameplay ist im weitesten sinne so wie half life 2 du hast also die waffen
aus den alten spielen das bringt dir aber nicht viel weil du damit eben das was das
spiel besonders macht einfach komplett umgehst also diese ganzen bewegungs sachen du benutzt
deine hände um mit irgendwas zu interagieren das gibt es ja gar nicht und teilweise kann
man das doch dann nur mit konsolen kommandos irgendwie türen öffnen oder irgendwelche
mechanismen bedienen das ist also die eine variante die habe ich mir jetzt aber nicht
im detail angeschaut was ich mir im detail angeschaut habe ist eine emulation von der
virtual reality für maus und taster fuck da tut dir ja der kopf weh alter also fuck das
so normalerweise mit einem oder muss ja kotzen wenn du das siehst in den händen macht maus
und tastatur das ist alles erst mal diese tools die man dazu braucht die sind erst mal
kostenlos aber das ganze ist nicht ohne weil es gibt momentan auch noch keinen komfortablen
so set up was hat man drückt einfach irgendwie auf eine exe und dann ist das alles installiert
und fertig sondern es erfordert schon einiges an gefrickel man muss ordner kopieren man
muss in die dateien sachen reinschreiben kein problem für uns neu software installieren
also es ist nicht ganz trivial gibt aber eine anleitung dazu die verlinkt euch auch unten
von dem ersteller von diesen sachen und damit habe ich das eigentlich auch ganz gut hingekriegt
das schwierige an der ganzen geschichte ist wenn man das alles dann installiert hat also
ich habe ungefähr eine halbe stunde gebraucht bis es dann so lief dann kommt schon mal
die erste ernüchterung weil es ist wahrscheinlich besser gewesen wenn ich hafl auf lx vorher
nie mit vr headset gespielt hätte weil es ist schon was ganz anderes also schon schon
mal dieser dieser eingangs wow effect wenn man schon das erste mal in dieser welt dieser
virtuellen welt steht der fehlt halt einfach komplett es ist halt einfach nur wie wenn
man sich das aus dem video anguckt man sieht es einfach nur flach und dann hat man sich
ja nur nicht mal bewegt weil dann geht eigentlich erst das los warum ich da so große probleme
damit habe dieses ganze meine hände werden jetzt mit maus und tastatur gesteuert hat
halt zig fallstricke und probleme die sich bringt weil ich kann so mein das ja voll für
den arsch das würde ich mir gar nicht an also man kann sich auch quälen mit einem spiel
richtung verändern und auch meine hingucke und die hände folgen dann einfach die ganze
zeit an meinen an meinen blickwinkel angeklebt aber so sachen wie ich möchte zum beispiel
weiter in den raum greifen möchte meine hand drehen und sowas das muss man alles mit den
gedrückt halten von irgendwelchen keyboard tasten machen und das schon ganz am anfang
muss man einfach nur seinen zeigefinger ausstrecken und auf so einen knopf an einem funkgerät
drücken weißt du wie lange ich gebraucht habe um das hinzukriegen weil du ja quasi
so völlig ungelenkt mit deinem finger in dem raum rum marschierst also das ist schon irgendwie
eine totale tortur dann ist das nächste ding die technik also während das jetzt auf der
valve index alles optimiert ist und das eigentlich eine idiotensichere experience ist ist das
natürlich alles von einem ich würde sagen begabten bastler gebaut worden aber das ist
natürlich alles nicht darauf ausgelegt dass man das ohne ein VR headset spielt das heißt
in sachen das sieht so hakelig aus so viel schlechter ist das eigentliche spiel das
heißt die hand von oben einfach random kann sein wenn man irgendwie muss dauernd rein und
raus tappen weil man zwei bildschirme zwei anwendungen gleichzeitig betreiben muss eine
anwendung emuliert dieses VR headset die andere anwendung ist das eigentliche spiel du guckst
quasi wie durch so eine art fernrohr auf das spiel drauf das heißt du musst immer zwischen
solchen anwendungen hin und her nee das ist doch total performance ist schon optimierungsbedürftig
und dann kommt das nächste problem mit dazu das ist die ganze sache das ganze thema spiel
balance denn man kann das eigentlich nicht gut spielen also es wird jede simpelste aufgabe
wird zu einer unglaublichen tortur und du kannst das eigentlich auch nur auf dem einfachsten
schwierigkeitsgrad und stellenweise auch nur mit god mode spiel einfach weil du halt so unfähig
also diese ganzen geschichten das würde ich mir im leben nicht antun ganz ehrlich dann spiele
ich lieber gar nicht ich normalerweise drücke ich die taste auf dem controller fliegt das
magazin raus dann greife ich an meinen rücken aus dem rucksack was raus zu holen das muss man auch
alles irgendwie mit diesen komischen kontrollen machen also es gibt shortcuts dafür aber das ist
halt wie ich weiß nicht so wie wenn du dance revolution mit der tastatur spielst ist ein
schlechtes beispiel wenn du super mario 64 versucht in 2d zu spielen auf dem super ns so es fehlt
halt einfach das fundamentale was das eigentlich so eine großartigen erfahrung macht und ich kann
eigentlich dieses spiel nur den leuten empfehlen die half life elix schon mal in vr erlebt haben
jetzt einfach so ein bisschen basteln und gucken wollen was möglich ist aber bitte bitte bitte
lasst das nicht euren ersten berührungspunkt mit half life elix sein weil selbst wenn ihr euch
dann die kosten spart für ein vr headset das sieht total hakelig aus und es so zu erleben
ihr bescheißt euch selbst macht es nicht wirklich wirklich schlimm ist dann ganz kurz mal das gesagt
du hast diese an diesen anderen weg nicht ausprobiert mit dieser developer version aber weißt du zu
vielleicht wo kriegt man die denn her ist es eine freischaltbare version oder wie kommt man da ran
also offiziell kann man die nicht einfach so herunterladen das hängt alles damit zusammen
dass es auf steam vom entwickler her werden frühere entwicklungsversionen eines jeden spiels als
back-up noch mal abgelegt was dazu gedacht ist eigentlich dass wenn entwickler ihr spiel
zerschießen mit einem patch können sie quasi noch mal die alte version wiederherstellen davon
gibt es oder gab es eine version von half life elix die noch lauter tools eingeschaltet hatte
mit denen man eben ohne vr diese sachen spielen kann einfach nur um schnell mal ein level rein
zu springen das auszuprobieren mittels der source 2 und das war damals hat nur für back fix den
gedacht sie haben das aber vergessen zu deaktivieren das heißt mit zusätzlichen tools kann man sich
diese alte version rauslassen und daran entwickeln dadurch dass jetzt eben mehr auch workshop support
für half life elix nach und nach kommt wird wahrscheinlich auch mehr in diese richtung passieren
aber stand jetzt das was ich ausprobiert habe diese true open wir lösung so heißt das ich kann es
einfach nicht empfehlen es macht einfach keinen spaß ist nette neste bastelei aber bitte probiert
das nicht aus wenn ihr spaß haben wollt also dann eher als alternative wenn man sagt man will das
spiel trotzdem sehen kann sich jetzt aber vielleicht kein vr headset leisten oder will
sich vielleicht auch nicht leisten weil vielleicht immer zu schlecht wird oder so aber man will diese
story erleben weil das hast du hast du ja auch oft erzählt dass das auch schon allein wegen der story
für half life sehr wichtig ist das spiel nicht nur cool sondern wichtig dann let's play schauen oder
ich meine normalerweise sagt man immer let's play schauen beraubt dich quasi der eigentlichen
spielerfahrung weil du selber machst finde ich nicht kommt auf das game an kommt echt auf das
game an es gab schon ein paar spiele die ich mir nur aufgrund von einem stream oder let's plays
gekauft haben so viel komfortabler als selber die die arme zu brechen auf dem keyboard und einfach
sachen zu machen guckt einfach in let's play von jemanden der das halt durchspielt dann kriegt
ihr die story auch mit oder und das ist halt einfach das non plus ultra spielt es selbst mit
einem vr headset besser wird es nicht aber das ist wirklich nur für hardcore bastler gedacht jetzt
hast du aber eingangs gesagt dass du kopfschmerzen hast wieso das dann normalerweise hat man doch
kopfschmerzen wenn man die vr version spielt das ist auch das ist nicht überrascht weil
tatsächlich dieses ganze rumprobieren es geht ja dann ganz oft auch um wie ist der der vergrößerung
effekt oder wie ist der abstand ich hab so nicht gespielt weil ich ich will mir eigentlich kein
vr headset kaufen nur für ein spiel man eben auch ein bisschen einstellen und das ist dann schon
übelkeitserregend bis man einen richtigen wert gefunden hat weil es eben nicht so von werf
getestet ist sondern man forscht selbst in solchen editor files rum und verlässt sich auf feedback
von leuten die das hat auch einfach nur so amateur mäßig ausprobiert haben und das über eine
längere zeit es belastet dann also es hat mir tatsächlich mehr kopfschmerzen bereitet jetzt
einfach mal zwei tage das auszuprobieren als irgendwie ganz half life alex mit vr headset
durchzuspielen kann ich verstehen würde ich auch kein bock drauf
so leute ich glaube ich werde jetzt was futtern
haben wir geguckt ich glaube ich gehe jetzt auf und was was essen ich habe übelst hunger
und außerdem wisst ihr ja wie das so ist muss ich mal aufs klo was er war im knast warum war
er dann im knast ich gucke mal kurz wem ich follow irgendeinen hosten können
nö nicht wirklich
okay leute also wir sehen uns am nächsten mal ich muss immer ganz schnell gucken habe ich nicht
vielleicht in den subs vergessen das passiert mir in letzter zeit öfters mal
falls ich das nicht gesehen habe dankeschön für den sub excellent subscription ich bin mal weg wir
sehen uns nächsten stream letzter zeit relativ häufig na bis dann machs gut zu